HOLD ON THE. ALL RIGHT THE
SECOND ON PO SAFETY WILL BE AS-
WELL WE WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS.
IN RE TO THE CODE NINE NUMBER
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES SO
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORTH
PRACTICES TO THROUGH. THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE IS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL SOME OF. MEMBERS ARE.
REMOTELY WILL BE. ONE UNDER.
THE TEN. DAY. SENATOR BREAUX IF
YOU HAVE A STATE PERSON WHO IS
ASSISTING COULD YOU THAT PERSON
FOR ME NOW. HER NAME'S HEATHER.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU FOR THAT.
RIGHT WELL I TRIED TO STILL
JEFF MY MASK YOUR- NO IT'S
BETTER OKAY. HI I APPRECIATE
YOUR FORMING A- SO AS WE IN
CENTER MOREAU YOU DID EXACTLY
RIGHT YOU ARE MUTE YOUR CELL TO
ANSWER MIKE NOW YOU MUTE
YOURSELF WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
SO. YOU KNOW THAT WHEN YOU WANT
ME TO YOU YOU CAN YOU SHOULD
THE RACIAL HAND IN THE AND ALSO
IT MY COMPUTER AND OF COURSE
HIT ON YOU WHERE YOU START
SPEAKING. TO ALLOW ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTINCT
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND OF IF
DEAR PEOPLE ARE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT TO BUY WILL ALLOW THEM
AND THEN WILL FOLLOW THAT WITH
A TELECONFERENCE. TEST ME. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO.
BUY PUBLIC THROUGH THE TELL.
THERE A NUMBER A AXIS ON OUR
CAN BE WEBSITE. AND WILL ALSO
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN THE
NUMBER FOR TODAY IS. ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND YOU SEE A
SCREEN. AND THE CODE. TO SIX
FOUR THREE FIVE NINE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO I WON
THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. YOU PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME IN YOU WAIT FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THAT CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THE TOP HE HERE
SHE CALL ONE NUMBER YOU'LL ON
MUTED AND YOU ARE THEN READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID IT STICK
IT BACK. THE YOU ARE WHAT
HEARING ON. THIRTY TEST. OVER
THE FOR. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
I MAINTAINED TO THE HEARING AS
IS. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
JUST MAY REMOVE FROM THE ME
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR CONNECT
NEED. WELL EVERY HAS BEEN MADE
TO STE HEARING. CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS AND IS CO TO THIS MAN
IS DISCUSSED. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. THAT
ARE HEARING TODAY BEYOND WHAT
I'VE JUST DESCRIBED ALL THE
PROCEDURES WILL BE FOLLOWING.
WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR BILLS. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. TWELVER ON
CONSENT. HOWEVER THERE ARE TWO
THAT HAVE BEEN PULLED AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT WEBER IT'S
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA
AND AB TWO SIX SIX NINE
SANTIAGO HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. AB EIGHT FOUR
SIX. ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE THE
BILL HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW DO I HAVE
A QUORUM YET NO SO I DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM YET SO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT WE
CAN BEGIN HEARING EVEN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. SO WHAT I WANT TO DO
IS START THE FIRST BILL WAS TO
BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL BUT SINCE SENATOR
WIENER IS HERE AND THE SECOND
BILL THAT'S NOT ON CONCERT WAS-
YOUR SCHEDULE SENATOR WIENER
DIPPERS AND THAT'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA'S BILL AB ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE ARE YOU READY
PERCENT THAT ALRIGHT SO WE WILL
SKEWS ME. POLL JEEZ WHAT'S THE
ISSUE. YEAH WE HAVE OUR WE ARE
OUR CASE FALL MY KIND OF OKAY
LET ALL RIGHT WE WERE WE CHECK
AND SEE VERY WITNESSES
OTHERWISE I. THE WE HOPE THAT
HAVE THE WAY FOR A ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE. ON THE PHONE LINES
BECAUSE SINC I MENTIONED WE
HAVE QUITE A LOT OF BILLS AND
WE DO WANT TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC- I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE GET THROUGH THEM TODAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE THEM YET. OKAY
WELL. THAT THE WORDS THAT PLAN
SEARCH- SO WE WILL WAIT FOR
SENATOR MITCHELL TO ARRIVE OR
UNTIL YOU TELL US THAT. THE
WITNESSES FOR AB ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE OR ON THE LINE. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE WAITING FOR
SINCE WE DIDN'T WE HAD THREE
BILLS CONSENT THEY SHOULD BE
READY. THE INDIVIDUALS
PRESENTING YES YES WE GAVE THE
OPTION OF COURSE FOR SENATORS
TO PRESENT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BILLS. AND THAT OPTION WAS
TAKEN AND I. WANT ONE YES YOU
ARE. YOU DO HAVE ONE. HOUSING
OKAY WELL HAVE THE CALL SENATOR
WIENER CA START. RIGHT CENTER
START ON HBO FOR FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GUARD BILL. TO
STAND UP FOR A MINUTE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM. ANCHOR GIANTS.
THAT SHOULD HERE A- WITH.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MAY
ARE TODAY I AM PRESENT BABY ONE
FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
SOME MEMBER CHRIS GARCIA. THE
BILL I'M FORTY FIVE IS. BY
QUALITY HEALTH FOR. AND IS A
PRIORITY BILL FOR OUR LGBT. THE
SIDE OF CAUCUS AB FORTY FIVE
WE'LL SIMPLIFY THE LOG FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS. AND WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS AND QUALITY OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND GENERAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR OUR
YOUTH PARTICULARLY. ARE ALSO BE
TO CHOOSE CURRENTLY MANDATED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS OF CHILD
ABUSE OR CONFUSING
INCONSISTENT. AND
DISCRIMINATORY AND SPECIFICALLY
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE SIXTEEN
WHEN YOU. THAT RANGE ARE HAVING
SEX WITH ONE ANOTHER A MANDATED
REPORTER LIKE A THERAPIST OR
TEACHER IF A CHILD COMES TO
THEM AND TALKS ABOUT HAVING SEX
WITH SOMEONE ELSE IN THE AGE
RANGE. IF IT IS BAD OF COURSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO REPORT ONLY
REPORTED IF THERE'S SOME
INDICIA A VERSION. FOR THIS
WELCOME. BUT IF IS ANY OTHER
FORM CHRIS MAY MáS. OUR REPORT.
AND NOT ME THAT YOUNG THEY HAVE
A AND- NOT TO COMMENT TO
THERAPIST THIRTY. ABOUT SEXUAL.
TO TRY TO GET. OR SO BECAUSE-
THAT MEANS THAT. THE MANDATE
REPORTER WILL HAVE TO REPORT ON
THE CHILD ABUSE OF AUTHORITIES
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE SEVENTEEN
OLD HAVING NON. INTERCOURSE
ANOTHER SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WILL
HAVE REPORTED KNOWS WHATSOEVER
PERMANENT. LGBT TO PEOPLE BUT
ALL HARM NOT A TEACHER. OUR
KIDS A ROCK IT'S A VOTE IT'S
FIVE ONE WAS A LEAVE TO HAVE
ANY KIND OF INTER. OTHER THAN
THAT ENERGY. AND SO LAW WILL
ENSURE THAT WE EQUAL LIVESTREAM.
IT WILL TELL OF. THREE ONE IS.
I ENDED. OF COERCION. BLOCK OF
CONCERN A BUT BALLING SECTOR
ACTS WILL NO LONGER. MANDATE
WITH. A SERVICE START ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU CAN
HEAR FOR YOUR FOR WITNESS SINCE
THE AND I'D NOT STATE THIS IN
OPENING BUT I WILL NOW BECAUSE
OF THE NAY. OF THE HEARINGS
WITH THIS ROOM PEOPLE CALLING
IN SUCH WE HAVE. COULD SO WE
WILL HAVE TO WITH AND- BUT
THERE TO TIME IS THREE. SO WITH
THAT STAR WITH. THE FIRST ONE
SUPPORT. AND GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CANYON ON THE
OF QUALITY. WHICH FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS HAS LED GOLDEN
STATE RIGHT ON THE KEEP WALL.
AND FORTUNATELY THE FOUR YEARS
WE HAVE YET TO SEE OF HOW LIVE
CATCH UP TO IT I. I'M NOT WHY
WE'RE PROUD ON. FORTY FIVE
UNLIKE. OTHER WHEN UP EIGHT ONE
THAT I AM WE TREAT THEIR TYPES
OF FACTS AND MORE EGREGIOUS
THAN OTHER ALL NOTIFY ME. I'M
SAN. HAVE BEEN AND I. MAKE IT
HARDER TO REPORT ABUSE OR
SUSPECTED ABUSE BUT IT WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR OF BE SUPPLY
YOU CAN GET THEM HEALTH THAT
THEY- ACTUALLY BY NOW AND MAKE
NO MISTAKE THIS IS A FOR THE
HEALTH. YEAH BUT ALL THE MEN OF
CRISIS HERE FROM OUR PART THE.
OUTLINES ARE RECEIVING MORE
CALL. I'LL BUT USUALLY ONLY ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THEIR EYES AND
BY WHO ARE ALSO AT HOME OFTEN
WITH THE CORE AND MEMBERS AND
ALLOW HEALTH ARE IMPORTANT AND-
WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE ARE
YOU HAVE MENTAL HEALTH REPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO SURVIVE
EXISTING LAW HOW. BACK IN
THIRTY. REPORTER SUPPORT EACH
OTHER ANY QUALITY AND I COULD
CAL SHOULD MEANS LOT THAT ARE
JUST. OR THAT MAKE ANOTHER TO.
FOR HELP WITH TWO THIRDS OF. SO
THIS IS A FUN SO. UNNECESSARY
BELCH THE MENTAL HEALTH. AND WE
RESPECT. URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NAY WHAT.
AND THIS IS A PRINCIPLE WITH.
BREAD A GOOD MORE GENERAL AND
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
THIS IMPORTANT UP I'M JENNIFER
OUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY. REPRESENTING THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND LICENSE ASSOCIATED. IN
CALIFORNIA. ON THE COURT OF AB
ELEVEN FIVE THIS BILL LEMONADE
THAT THAT MANDATED REPORTERS
UNDER THE CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT REPORTING ACT REPORTS
TESTIFIED CONSENSUAL SEXUAL
CONDUCT. INVOLVING MINERS.
ANSWER THREE DEATH AND BECAUSE
THERE'S NO TO COMPLY STATUTES
LÏNG AND END UP NAY DESCRIBED
BY OUR- AGENTS IN APARTMENT CAN
JIM AFFAIRS. PROTECT LBGT
MINORS FROM PROSECUTION.
MISALIGNMENT INSTEAD TO MERE
REGULATORY GUIDELINES IN RECENT
COURT RULINGS WILL HELP TO
ELIMINATE CONFUSION FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS LIKE IN A
LICENSE IN THE STATE. THE
STATUTE IS NOT TO PROTECT TO
PUT OUR- Q. MIND FROM ARISING
FROM THE LACK OF CONSISTENCY
MINARETS THE PROSECUTION. FOR
THESE REASONS CAMP SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. THANKS SO
MUCH AND THANKS WITNESSES FOR
WITHIN THE THREE MINUTES NOW WE
WILL HEAR FROM. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND WE APPRECIATE IF
YOU JUST NOT ONLY APPRECIATE WE
REQUIRED JUST YOUR NAME
AFFILIATE. AND ARE WE HAVE TO
DO- SORRY BEFORE WE DO IT ON
THE PHONES ARE THERE ANYONE IN
PHYSICALLY IN THIS ROOM WHO
WANTS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. ALRIGHT SIR ANYONE
AND OTHER HEARING ROOM. NO ALL
RIGHTS ARE OPERATOR YOU CAN
HAVE OUR FIRST- WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD IT IF YOU
ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE HE
MAY NEED TO PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO-
WE'LL GO FIRST. NINE TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FORTY TWO. BURKE BECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL RIGHT. I CAN. HEAR
YEAH AND THE NEXT ONE. GO TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY EACH LINE
THIRTY EACH YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE AT DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THREE
SIX. GOOD ONE NUMBER FOR SIX
LINE FOR SIX PLEASE GO AGAIN.
YES WE'RE VAN HOMES
REPRESENTING THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES ON THE
BORDERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT. THE LINE FORTY FOUR LINE
FOR. GOOD MORNING AMANDA LEVY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IT WILL GO
TO LINE THIRTY NINE LINE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MON
SHERMAN MEMBERS BANDFULL OF
ALL ON BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. NEXT. IF NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. ALRIGHT
SO BEFORE I GOING VERY WELL I
APOLOGIZE IF THAT ONE MORE
PERSON IN THE QUEUE. ONE MOMENT
HERE. BUT I'M NOT. WHAT
POLITICAL OF THE DATA COMING
OUT OF THE HOUSE OF CARDS.
THEY'LL GET. SORRY WE- THIS IS
MOSTLY JUST NAME AND IN COURT.
ALL RIGHT I HAVE ONE OTHER
PERSON IN THE QUEUE WILL BE
JUST ONE MOMENT. YOU THAT IS
GONNA BE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
ALIGNING TWO TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DANIEL CARRIES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. ANY OTHERS. ALRIGHT
SO NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
WHEN IN THE QUEUE SAID NO OKAY
SO WE DO NOT DO NOT THANK YOU
SO BEFORE WE HEAR FROM THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CALL THE ROLL THE- SECRETARY WE-
THE ROLE. SKINNER I'M HERE
MOORLACH PRESENT MOORLACH
PRESENT BRADFORD YOUR BRADFORD
HERE JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
MITCHELL. MORALE AROUND HERE
FOR ALL PRESENT REMOTELY WIENER
PRESIDENT WHEN OUR PRESENT
CORMS BEEN ESTABLISHED. GREAT
THANK YOU- NOW WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE WHOEVER THE KEY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION IF THERE
IS ANY- IN TOTAL THREE MINUTES
ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THAT'S GREAT. BUT
OUR RATE YES IS THERE ANYONE
WHO CALLED IN. OR IS THERE
ANYONE HERE PHYSICALLY WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION FIRST IN THIS
HEARING ROOM. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE REMOTE HEARING ROOM
WHO'S IN OPPOSITION. FOR ANYONE
WHO CALL IN WHO'S IN OPPOSITION.
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE WHO'S CALLED IN FOR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. MORE
OUT INCREASED PRESS ONE ST ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IT FOR
OPPOSITION YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO MRS AB ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. WE
HAVE NO IN THE QUEUE EXCELLENT
ALRIGHT SO NOW JUST A SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUESTION OR COMMENT. WE HAVE
THE MOST. SEEING ANY OTHER-
QUESTIONER COMMON IT LET'S SEE
AND MY COLLEAGUE REMOTELY IT.
DOES NOT OF HIS HAND UP SO
LET'S DO THE MOST WOULD BE. TO
PASS TO ONE SECOND WHERE'S MY
TO PASS TO APPROACH. NOT YES
YOU APPROACHED US IN WITH THAT
THAT'S OCEAN DO PASSED TWO
PROBES LET SEVERAL CALL AB
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE THE PASTOR
PURPOSE SKINNER BY. MARLA MORE
LIKE NOT VOTING BRADFORD OUR
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MORALE DEL VERANO.
WIENER HI WHEN ARE II BUT THE
ALARM CALL FOR SENATOR MITCHELL.
RIGHT THE BILL IS. FOUR ZERO AT
THE FOUR ONE FOUR ONE AT THE
MOMENT BUT WE'LL PUT IT O CALL
AND THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER SO
LET'S SEE SENATOR MITCHELL'S
NOT HERE YET 2% AB SEVEN THIRTY
TWO. THE LET'S SEE IF THE- IF
THERE IS ANYONE ON THE LINE FOR
AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON STILL WHICH WE
BE NOW UP. SENATOR BRADFORD
PRESENT THAT THAT'S AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR AND IF THE WITNESSES
ARE ON THE LINE HE COULD
PROCEED WITH THAT. OKAY FOR.
AND. IF YOU KNOW FOR AND WE NOT
HAVE JOHN. OKAY. YES CAN YEAH
IF THERE'S FOLKS WHO ARE
WATCHING MONITORING THIS
HEARING I WILL READ BILLS THAT
ARE ON CONSENT SO YOU'LL KNOW
THAT. IN THE FILE SO THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET PRETTY QUICK SO THAT
BILLS AROUND CAN CENTER AB FOUR
SIX FIVE IS EGGMAN. ONE SECOND.
ALL RIGHT ALL STILL READ THEM
BUT- WE DO THAT WE COULD DO
THAT CELEBRITIES READ WHAT THEY
ARE SO AB EIGHT FOUR SIX RISK
FROM CONSENT WE START OUT WITH
AB FOR SIX FIVE EGGMAN AB EIGHT
FOUR SIX BURKE WAS PULLED. ME
NOT. OUT IS ON. AB. TWELVE
NINETY NINE IS ON CONSENT. OF
AB NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IS ON
CONSENT. AB TWENTY FOURTEEN IS
ON CONSENT. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY ONE IS ON CONSENT. AB
TWENTY SIX OH SIX IS ON CONSENT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE IS ON
CONSENT AB THIRTY FORTY THREE
IS CONSENT AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE IS CONSENT SENATOR EXCUSE
ME- AB EIGHT FORTY SIX WAS
ADDED BACK TO CONSENT WAS ADDED
BACK YEAH OKAY EVEN KNOWING
THAT THE OPENING IT WAS PULLED.
EXCUSE ME WAS A IS OFTEN WAS ON
OUR PHONE OKAY POLICIES. THEN
THE ADDITION TO WHAT I JUST
READ WAS THE AB EIGHT FORTY SIX
IS ON CONSENT AND THEN YES
SENATOR MORLOCK. FRIEDMAN ONE
THREE. ONE SECOND LET ME LOOK.
ONE SECOND IT IS FOR. THIS BOOK.
WHEN DID YOU SAY TWENTY THREE
FORTY. THAT'S NOT. TWENTY THREE
FORTY ASSOCIATION. OUR YOU'RE
RIGHT I DID NOT READ THAT.
BECAUSE IT'S THE STAPLE ON BY
SHEET COVERED IT. AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY IS ALSO AND CONSENT
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK FOR
MAKING THEIR CORRECTION SO WE
NOW HAVE AN ACCURATE LIST. YES
THERE WAS REMOVED FROM AGENDA
IT'LL BE ON X. WEEK SUCH. SO MS
WEBBER'S AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT WAS PULLED I DENOUNCE AT
THE BEGINNING BUT THAT'S JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION FROM. I
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER MORE
LIKE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OF A LET US
CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT COUNTER
SENATOR SKINNER. BY SKINNER
ADDED MORE LACK MOORLACH AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
AYE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MORALE.
RELY RURAL HI WIENER WIENER
ONLINE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF
INFORMATION YES WE WILL HOLD
THAT CONSENT CALENDAR RULE OPEN
AND NOW- TO ADD OR MISSING
MEMBER BUT WE WILL NOW GO TO.
FILE ITEM SEVEN BE THIRTEEN OH
FOUR. WHICH IS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON BUT SENATOR
BRADFORD WILL PRESENT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO NO FOUR
STATED FOR SOME OF WALDRON IF
THIS BILL CREATES A CALIFORNIA.
MATT OR MEDICAL ASSISTANT
REENTRY INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE FOR A LEASE
WITH TIME CREDIT UP TO A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OFF THEIR
PAROLE FOR PARTICIPATING AND
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS OR PRINCETON
NATIONALIST LEADER DROP.
FINDING THAT PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT FOR CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS REDUCES BOTH
SUBSTANCE USE AND CRIMINAL
RECIDIVISM RECIDIVISM. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES CDC
ARE RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE SOME JUST SOME
SORT SINCE A BIRD I CAN TALK
THESE THINGS ARE USED THIS
ORDER TREATMENT AND INTO. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS INCLUDED-
SPOT SEVENTY ONE MILLION
SEVENTY ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DENTAL MEANT AND- SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM TO
EXPAND MEDICAID MEDICATION TO
TREATMENT ROUTE CCIR THE REST
REAL TO OPIOID USE PULLING
RELEASED FROM A CORRECTIONAL
SETTING IS EXTREMELY HIGH
MAJORITY APART. ABOUT COMMUNITY
TREATMENT FOR COMPLETION. AB
THIRTEEN OH FOR FURTHER OUR
BEST MAN AND STOPS DISTRICT
WITHIN THE CRY SAID BY CREATING
AND SENATE BOWL. IMPROVE TO
OKAY TREATMENT POST. THIS WILL
BE ANDOF ROOM PROCESS THERE
CAN AND A AS A THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER KENTUCKY'S
LEGISLATION THAT WERE
ADMINISTERED UNDERS SECRETARY
JOHN TILLY WHO WAS ON THE LAW
TO TESTIFY TODAY SECRETARY
TILLY NATIONALLY RECORD I SURE
CAN OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
INNOVATIVE DROP POP THESE. ARE
AND ME FIVE TWO PRODUCT
LEGISLATURE FORMER KENTUCKY
JUST AND POP SAFETY CABINET
SECOND. THANKS FOR SENIOR. AT
THE KEY ON CRIMINAL. SECRETARY
KELLY HAS SPENT NEARLY THREE
DECADES WORKING FOR MORE FAIR
JUST AND EFFECTIVE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE HAVE THEM ON
THE LINE TO SPEAK- BRIEFLY ON
BEHALF OF THE BENEFITS THIS
MEASURE AND I RESPECT. YOUR
THANK YOU YES WE CAN HAVE OUR-
WITNESS- SECRETARY KILL YOU
PROCEED PLEASE. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD WILL BOTH OF YOU AND
I- AGAIN AND GRATIFIED IN SO
PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU JUST FOR
A FEW MOMENTS THE DAY OUT
STARTED MUST. MAKES IT I ABOUT.
START SAYING WHAT HE SAID
SENATOR BRADFORD COVERED WHY
THIS BILL IS A NO BRAINER WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT WHY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM WHAT. THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ALL PLAY WHITE SAVES
LIVES. ME TELL YOU WHY WE FOUND
SUCCESS SENATE- BEYOND THE
BEING INCREDIBLE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. OF NEARLY FOUR TO
ONE AGAIN FOR DAHLE. IT IT IS
BUILT PROPOSITION THAT CARE
IT'S WORK BETTER THAN STICKS IN
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THIS ONE BEING FRONT AND CENTER
IN THAT REGARD THE INCENTIVES-
THAT ARE GIVEN IN IN THIS BILL
AND IN OUR BILL. YOUR WHAT
MAKES THE DIFFERENCE IN MAKING
SURE THERE IS ROBUST
PARTICIPATION MAKING CERTAIN
THAT WE GET EVERYONE. BENEFIT
FROM IT EIGHTEEN. IN THIS TYPE
OF CONTINUED AFTER CARE WE GET
THEM IN WITH THOSE AT LEAST
GOING TO LOSE PEOPLE WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE. FRANK AND THE
REST OF RELAPSE WITHIN BRED FOR
NOTICE MUCH. THE MOMENT. THAT
AN INMATE STEPS OUT OF THAT
JAIL OR PRISON DOOR AND INTO
THAT WORLD SO TO GET THEM
CONNECTED IMMEDIATELY AS WE DID
WITH THE SOCIAL SERVICE
COMMISSION. TO ASSIST AND MATT
BENEFITS. IN RE UP MEET UP AT
AND IN CONNECT THEM AND MAKE
SURE THEY IT HERE. SANDERS SET
FOR CAN TAKE. MAY THE AND ALSO
EVERYTHING THAT GOES THAT THAT
THE CONTINUED AFTER CARE THE
CAN BE PER. ABOUT A NUMBER OF
RESOURCE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
TO BE MONITORED AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S COMPLIANCE FROM
PROBATION IMPOSSIBLE YOUR UNITY
SUPERVISION. SO WITH THAT I
KNOW THAT IS A FAIR LEVEL
APPROACH. HOW LEVEL. COVERAGE
OF THAT HOW WOULD YOU TO PUT IT
IN A FIGHT IS THE BEST PRACTICE
WE'VE BEEN VERY. HUMBLED BY THE
ATTENTION WE NEED AT THE BEST
PRACTICE ENGLISH. BANDS AND
MANY OTHERS. I WOULD. I KNOW
WHAT IS ON THE BACK TRACK
BECAUSE IT MAY SO MUCH SET. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU AND WE SEE
IF THERE ARE MEMBER. AFTER HEAR
FROM. THE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO
FIRST ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT VISIT IN THIS ROOM.
BEING NINE THERE ANY ANY OTHER.
IT'S ME GOOD MORNING EXCUSE ME
WE ARE JOHN VALENCIA
REPRESENTING ALCHEMY IS WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BRADFORD FOR HIS
PRESENTATION ENTERED YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN OH
FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH GLAD TO
SEE HIM FIRST AND EVERYONE'S.
RIGHT SO LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES WHO
WANTS TO BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE OF REMOTE ROOM A NOT ON
THE PHONE LINE TO SPEAK
ANSWERED OF A. THREE YES. JERRY
DO. THE LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
OF. THE ATHLETE MARTINEZ
WITHOUT FOR SAFE ENOUGH IS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT
ABOUT ONLINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LIGHTED
METED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
NOT RESPONSIBLE ONE ALIGN FIFTY
EIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS FUNDING
AS- POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CUT
FIFTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR. THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AS A REMINDER SELECT
ACTUAL SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO SHOW
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT BUT
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE I APOLOGIZE
ONE MOMENT IF.
I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE WILL
OPEN A LINE OF LINE FIFTY SEVEN
POINT EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WOULD PERFORM. SUPPORT ONCE
AGAIN A REMINDER LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND AT THE TIME
WITH NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU LETTERS
SEAT THERE'S NO ONE. DID THE AS
A LEAD OFFICE AND LET US SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY ONE IS ANYONE IN
OUR HEARING ROOM WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. THIRTEEN OH FOUR. GENTLEMEN
IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN A SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE RIGHT SO WE'LL
GO TO THE DíAS- SENATOR
JACKSON ADEQUATE GO AHEAD
SENATOR JEFF ACTUALLY NOT NOT A
QUESTION A- AN APPRECIATION FOR
BRINGING. AND I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING TO HAVE ONE OF OUR
REPUBLICAN SISTERS. WHO IS THIS
I HAPPEN TO HAVE HAD AN OFF
NEEDED TO TALK TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON. WHO'S A SMALL
BUSINESS PERSON AND WHO MADE IT
A POINT TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
IN RETURN THE CARD ASIAN. THIS
AND THEREFORE THE IS TO COME TO
THIS CONCEPT OF FREE OF. AND IS
QUITE AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT FOLKS FIT THEY DO GET OUT
OF. AND I THINK THIS IS A- THE
TO MOVE FROM XIN THAT THE BAY
WAY TO KILL PEOPLE IS TO
INCARCERATE THEM. FOR
PUNISHMENT MOST PEOPLE IN ARE
THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM AND IF WE ARE WILLING
TO REST THEIR PROBLEMS WHEN
THEY COME BACK OUT THEY WILL
RESPOND OF IT. IS THE PROBLEM
CORRECT. AN THE I AM REMINDED
OF AN EXPERIENCE COUPLE YEARS
AGO. THE SENATE TOOK A TRIP TO
PORTUGAL AND SPAIN. AND
PORTUGAL SORT OF LIKE KENTUCKY
RECOGNIZED THAT TO SIMPLY
INCARCERATE PEOPLE WAS NOT
SOLVING THEIR PROBLEMS. AND SO
THEY LOOKED AT A LOT OF THEIR
ADDICTION ISSUES AS A HEALTH
ISSUE NOT A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUE. AND THEY REDUCED THEIR
RATE OF. IT WILL NOT CHEST OF
CONVICTION BUT AND
INCARCERATION BUT OF ACTUAL-
ADDICTION. BECAUSE THE TREATED
THE PROBLEM. AND IT IT WAS
REALLY QUITE AN EYE OPENING
EXPERIENCE THE FACT THAT OUR
FRIENDS IN KENTUCKY ARE WAY
AHEAD OF US ON THIS KENTUCKY
ISN'T KNOWN AS FAR AS I KNOW IS
A- SORT OF A TOUCHY FEELY
GRANOLA TYPE PLAY IT'S PRETTY
HARD CO. IN MANY BUT- WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT THIS AND THE
REASON I'M SPEAKING MADAM CHAIR
IN. YOU NEED. TO REPORT OUR
TION OF WHAT TO ACRONYM JUSTICE
IS AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHOSE BEHAVIOR JUSTIFIED
INCARCERATIONS BUT WHILE THEY
WERE DATING THE WORK ON TRYING
TO HELP THEM CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR. ADDICTION IS A- BY
ALLOWING US TO GIVE INCENTIVES
TO PEOPLE. TO TRY TO THAT
BEHAVIOR TO OVERCOME. THEIR
ADDICTION TO HELP THEM DO THAT
SO THE WHEN THEY GET OUT THE
KNOCK IN RECIDIVIST TODAY ARE
ACTUALLY GET THE TOOLS THE
ABILITY TO TURN THEIR LIVES
AROUND IS I THINK AN OVERDUE
CONCEPT THAT WE IN CALIFORNIA'S.
HAVE BEEN MADE TO THE GAME ON
END SO. I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL I DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN IS A CO
AUTHOR I DON'T TO THEIR FREE
MUCH. BUT BASED UPON WHAT I.
HAVE ONE AT A FOCUSING ON THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE. ARE USUALLY
IN CARS. FOR PRETTY DELIVERY
SINCE AND WE DON'T ADDRESS
THOSE WHY THEY'RE IN CARS. WE
WILL CAN TO HAVE THE HIGHEST
RECIDIVISM. I AM THE CAR. AMONG
THE- I AM. THAT FOR BROUGHT
BILL. HELLO A SISTER IN ACROSS
THE AISLE RECCA THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS I'M HOPING THIS WILL BE
A BI PARTISAN ISSUE GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE IT IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE SO WITH THAT I
WOULD ALSO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU MA'AM. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER COMMON QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT SO- WE HAVE A MOTION
WHICH IS TO PASS TWO PROBES AND
WE CAN PUT IN THE REQUEST TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE CAN'T-
INCLUDE IN THE IN. THE CO
AUTHORS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE SIMPLY MEMBER HERE TO
CONSENT BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY IN
IT IN REQUESTED SENATOR JACKSON
LIKE TO BE ADDED TO SCHOOL OUT
THERE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. AND THINK
THE IMPORTANT. BOTH THE
PRESENTER AND TO THE WITNESS
DID IS THAT MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR ADDICTIONS
THERE'S MORE AND MORE. RESEARCH
AND DATA SUPPORTING MEDICALLY
SISTER TREATMENT AND WITH THE
NUMBERS OF THE DICK OPIATE
ADDICTED PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY
NOW. TO FOR US TO RECOGNIZE THE
SCIENCE BASED EVIDENCE OF THE
EFFICACY OF MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT I THINK IT'S VERY
WEISS AND INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
THE VISUALS WHO HAVE THESE TYPE
OF ADDICTIONS AS SOMEHOW WEEK
SO I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THAT IT ALSO A
VALUE. EIGHT HIGH TREE THAT HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
OF COURSE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL WE HAVE THE MOTION ON
IT BRADFORD ON MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF ON I THINK THIS TO
COMMONSENSE MEASURE. BUT A
MEASURE IT SHOULDN'T BE ANY OF
THE BLACK COMBAT. WELCOME HAS
BEEN MAKE PAYMENT FOR OVER
FORTY. OF TREATMENT AND I HATE
TO ALWAYS USE RACE BUT I'M
GONNA MAKE THE PRALLEL NON TO
WHITE FOLKS START DYING FROM
OPIOID ADDICTION THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY- SEE A NEED TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT STARTED
IMPRISONMENT SO THIS IS COMMON
SENSE MEASURE AND I'M HONORED.
TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF MISS
WALDRON AND I RESPECT FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. FOR IT THREE OUT THE
MOTION THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION
THE PAST TWO. UP TO CALL THE
ROLL. AT THIRTEEN OH FIVE
MOTION BY SENATOR JACKSON THE
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
SKINNER BY. OTHERS WERE NOT HI
MORE LUCK. MOORLACH HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH MITCHELL. MITCHELL
AYE MORALE. SENATOR MORAL YOU
HAVE TO ORALLY SAY NOT VOTING
WHEN YOU REMEMBER. AROUND THE
ABILITY THANK YOU. SENATOR
WIENER. SENATOR WINNER ON THE
BILL IS. SIX TO ZERO ALL RIGHT
THE BILL'S PAST SIX ZERO AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO. THE FIRST
BILL THAT WE WERE GOING TO HEAR
WILL RETURN TO IT IT'S
FIRELIGHT TO AB TWENTY TWO AND
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA THIS
BILL THAT'S AB SEVEN THREE TWO
SENATOR MITCHELL IS GOING TO
PRESENT LET ME MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE. THE IS ON THE LINE. TO
RECOVER LEAD WITNESSES FOR YES
WE DO GREAT SO SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU CAN PRESENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND IT'S OKAY FOR ME TO
PRESENT HERE FROM MY SEAT. AT
WORK WORK IN TERMS OF CAMERA TO
THE PODIUM. CONSERVE ANSWERED
I'M ON CAMERA SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WOULD BE A PROBLEMS LIKE
IT SHOULD WORK I'M ON CAMERA SO
I GUESS IT'S OKAY. YEAH MY OKAY
WE GOT A THUMBS UP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY PROUD TO
PRESENT TO- EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ROB BONTA I'M PROUD
BECAUSE I'M A CO AUTHOR AND-
MADAM CHAIR YOU WILL- ELEMENTS
OF THIS BILL WILL SEVEN VERY
FAMILIAR TO YOU. AB TWO WOULD
IMPROVE. THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE FOR INCARCERATED
PREGNANT CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY
JAILS A I'M STATE PRISON. A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT SUPPORT
PREGNANT THREE WOMEN. PRISONS
BY WEALTHIEST NATIONS WITH THE
SIEVE CERTAIN REQUIRE IN A
COUNTY JAILS. EIGHTY SEVEN
THREE TWO WOULD CODIFY INTO LAW
REGULATIONS FOR STATE PRISONS
AND EXTEND EXISTING
PROTECTIONS.AGAIN TO COUNTY
JAILS UNDER AB SEVENTY TWO
COUNTY JAILS WILL BE REQUIRED
TO DO THE FOLLOWING SCHEDULE
PREGNANT INCARCERATED PERSONS
FOR OBSTETRIC EXAMS IN PRENATAL
CARE VISITS. ASSIGNED PREGNANT
ACOSTA RATED ASSIST TO LOWER.
AND LOWER TIER HOUSING ALLOW A
PREG INCARCERATED PER TEND TO
HAVE SOME PERSON PRESENT DURING
CHOI. GET PREGNANT INCARCERATED
PERSONS ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
PROGRAM. IMPROVISE CARS FOR THE
PURPOSE WITH PULSE PART OF
EXAMINATIONS. THESE ARE ALL
CURRENTLY REQUIRED THEY PRISON.
ALSO YEAH BUT SHACKLING OF
PREGNANT CARS PERSON. IN BOTH
STATE PRISONS IN COUNTY JAILS
THAT WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT THE
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT A PREGNANT
INCARCERATED PERSONS.
CALIFORNIANS TO PROVIDE
DIGNIFIED AND COMPASSIONATE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT TO INCARCERATED
PREGNANT CALIFORNIANS WHETHER
IN STATE PRISON A COUNTY JAIL
FOR ALL THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THREE TWO.
FOR THANK YOU ARE CENTER
MITCHELL FOR PRESENTING WILL
NOW GO TO THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS- FROM ACLU GO AHEAD ON
THE PHONE LINES. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
A B. B. FOR WHILE I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
PROUD POSTPONED AB.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. SYSTEM IS
INCONSISTENT AND DANGEROUSLY
INADEQUATE. WEATHER PERSON
RECEIVE ADEQUATE SERVICES
DEPENDS ON WHAT JAIL THEY
HAPPEN TO LAND IN AND WHICH
DOCTOR THEY HAPPENED TO SEE. IN
HUMANE AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM. I SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL SAID THE- CODIFY STATE
FOR THE RIGHT PATIENT EXTEND
THE PROTECTIONS THE COUNTY
JAIL. THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
MORE PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED IN
COUNTY JAILS AND LONGER PERIODS
OF. TIME THERE'S THIS IDEA. TO
LEARN ONLY FOR A FEW DAYS THEY
DON'T NEED ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE BUT THAT'S- A LONG. TRUE
TO THE- INCARCERATED WHEN CAL.
JAIL AND THESE WOMEN ARE NOT
EATING THE- HELL. YOU NEED. THE
THERE'S NOT A LOT FRESHLY
MANDATING THAT JAY PRO. BY WE
SPOKE IN WITH WOMEN HAVE TO
GIVE HELLO WOULD JUST THE
DOCTOR AND THE CRACK OFFICER
PRESENT WITHOUT THERE SOUTH
FAMILY. WE SPOKEN WITH WOMEN
WHO ARE PREGNANT OR SOUND I
FIND A TOP BUNK WHICH CAN BE
DANGEROUS FOR THEM AND THEIR
BABY. WE SPOKE AN AGREEMENT TO
ADD TO THEIR COMPANY BECAUSE
THEY WERE PROVIDED WITH ENOUGH
PADS AND TAMPONS. THESE ARE
BASED PRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE
NEEDS. AND THE BALLOT IN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS AN
EXISTING LEGAL DUTY TO PROVIDE
THAT HEALTHCARE TO INCARCERATED
PEOPLE. THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
HAS FOUND THAT WHEN EIGHT
INCORPORATE THE PERSON. COMES
RIGHT. FOR PROVIDE. THAT
PERCENT INDICATE PRODUCTOS PARA
CALIFORNIA. FAILING AB. TWO
WOULD SIMPLY PUT. THANK YOU AND
THEN- NEXT IS I BELIEVE AND-
JELLICO SANCHEZ. ELEVEN I AM
WITNESS ON NOVEMBER DELTA
FACTORS REPRESENTING THE YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER AT THE
PFISTER WARRIOR FREEDOM
COALITION MEMBER AND I AM
WRITING VIDAK ABOUT MINUTES
THAT I FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE I
WHICH WHEN I WAS INCARCERATED.
I ALREADY GOT HELP OUR LIKE
PRENATAL VITAMINS RIGHT BEFORE
WILL BRING TO PRESENT AT THAT
OUT REALLY TERRIFIED IN THE
COUNTY JAIL THE BOOK THAT I
FEEL LIKE. PEOPLE IN CARS GET
OTHER INMATE IN THERE WITH ME
BEING SHACKLED DOWN TO THE BAD.
LAW MILITARY THERE WILL DOESN'T
EVEN THE BED SHACKLED AND THEY
WOULD JUST BE YOU KNOW PRETTY
MUCH AGREED. AND I'LL CARE
PARKING HAVE MY BABY THERE. ARE
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS BEING THE
PRESS ADDED I SCHEDULE THE I.
W. WHERE WHEN I. DID NEAR DAY
TO GET THERE THE FOLLOWING
MORNING I WHEN LABOR. SO YEAH
W. THE THREE. CARE WILL NOT.
GIVEN TO ME WHY BECAUSE I TO BE.
IN ALL MEDICAL CLEARED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A BILL FOR I WILL.
NOT GIVEN HOW SERVICES THE-
WHAT I WENT INTO LABOR I. THE
PEOPLE THAT THE WERE NOT THERE
WERE NOT ADDED FOR TO BE ABLE
TO LIKE TAKE CARE OF ME BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NO SKILLED DAHLE. NO
LEARNING SKILLS DURING LIKE
THAT SO PRETTY MUCH WHEN I
WALKED INTO ON THE HOSPITAL I
WAS ARE YOU MEMBER WHY WORKING
GOING TO GENERAL HOSPITAL I
WOULD- JEAN ALL. IT'LL WHERE O
YOU A COM FOR. MY TAKE A FULL
NOW TO EVERYTHING I REMEMBER SO
UP HERE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW ALL
MY MOM WAS THE ONE ALWAYS WITH
ME ACT AVERY AND ON. THAT FLOWS
FROM BEING A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
BACK. AND I HAVE MULTI MEMBERS
I REMEMBER THE NURSE TOLD ME
LIKE YOU ON THE OLDER HAD I
MEAN WHICH WILL SOLD BAD YOU
KNOW ALL- AND THE GIVING BIRTH
TO MY DAUGHTER- ALL FOR. JACK
FOR THROUGH THE. GIVING THE-
ADD ALL STILL I HAD A CALL FROM
FROM. I WOULD BE WOULD NOT LET
ME IF DAUGHTER WILL GO TO FALL
CARE WHERE DID THEY IT BUT ABLE
TO SPEAK TO MY MOM MY WHO WOULD
NINETY A CALL SO I MEAN THAT
WORRIED OF JUST NOT LONG YOU'RE
DOING OLD IT AND JELLICO. AND
JELLICO COULD YOUR UP ONE OF
LET YOU GUYS KNOW THAT AS I CAN.
ACT WE STILL HAVE BEEN OVER.
EVEN THOUGH WERE VERY. WE DON'T
GET NOW I KNOW ANY HELP. MOLD
SERVICE WITHOUT THE WORD I WAS
JUST A BACKFLOW. YOU KNOW AND I
THINK THAT'S VERY. SAT THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SHARE
EARLIER. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL
BEFORE WE TO ANY I COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS WILL GO
TO THE OFFICE. I BELIEVE I HAVE
A OPPOSITE IS COREY C. O. I'M
SORRY YOU'RE RIGHT WE HAVE TO.
BUT THIS OKAY SO NOW WITH IN
SUPPORT AGAIN JUST NAME AND
ORGANIZATION LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THIS ROOM.
OUR EIGHTEEN NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN THE OTHER ROOM IS EMPTY
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES THIS IS WRITTEN IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO
NAME AND AFFILIATION. IF YOU
WANT TO GET INTO THE QUEUE YOU
WILL PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE ONE
THREE FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN.
GEN FLORI WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO THAT
FLYING SIX TWO THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT LINE
TO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. WE
HAVE WHY NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
LINE THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CATEGORY ON THE PRACTICE
PROJECT STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT NINE
FIVE EACH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KLEIN FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIFTY EIGHT IF YOU
WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE KEY WE
DO HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
OKAY WE'RE NOT GETTING A
RESPONSE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR LINE THREE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT A CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE ERIN ALLMAN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION. AND THE COURT
THANK YOU. BUT ALL MY NUMBERS
SIX THAT'S LINE FIVE. PLEASE WE
HAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY LINE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
GROW MARYLAND ROCKS THEN I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
WHEN STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE.
NO ADDITIONAL PARTICIPANTS ON
THE OUR ACTUALLY DO HAVE ONE
MORE ON THE PHONE TO BE- JUST A
MOMENT WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY
TWO LINE FOR TWO IS OPEN.
REBECCA GONZALEZ. THE CREATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE OUTLINED SIXTY FOUR-
THAT IS LINE SIX FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
BUT BEEN TRAINED ON BEHALF OF
THE HAVING OUR SAY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL- PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
AND THE PHONE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL NOW GO OUR KEY
WITNESSES OP. WHICH IS COREY SO
STILL OR FROM THE STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
COREY SOCIAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN THREE
TWO. EXISTING STATE REGULATION
REQUIRES THE HEALTH AUTHORITY
OF A CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
STATE OR LOCAL TO SET FORTH IN
WRITING POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
IN CONFORMANCE WITH APPLICABLE
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW. WHICH
ARE REVIEWED AND UPDATED AT
LEAST EVERY TWO YEARS ON A
NUMBER OF TOPICS INCLUDING
PROVISION FOR BEING IN CARE OF
PREGNANT AND- INMATES INCLUDING
PRENATAL AND POST PARTUM
INFORMATION AND HEALTH.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
ACCESS TO NECESSARY VITAMINS AS
RECOMMENDED BY A PHYSICIAN FROM
A TRAINING PROCEDURE CATION AN
INFILL CARE WE GOING TO THAT
IT'S- INAPPROPRIATE TO SET- USE
TREATMENT SCHEDULE
SPECIFICATIONS FOR CARE IN
STATUTE IS THAT DOING SO LIMITS
NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY. ALSO THE
UNFUNDED MANDATES CONTEMPLATED
BY THIS BILL RELATED TO
SPECIFIC COURSES OF PRENATAL
AND POST PARTUM CARE WITHOUT
REGARD TO LOCAL STANDARDS ARE
RESOURCES WILL BE EXTREMELY
COSTLY ESPECIALLY THE SMALL
COUNTIES NOT EVERY COUNTY WILL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS LEVEL
OF CARE WITHOUT EXTREMES
BUDGETARY PRESSURE IT ON JUST
RELATED TO IDENTIFYING SPECIFIC
ITEMS ARE COURSES OF CARE IN
FIFTY EIGHT DIVERSE COUNTIES.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST
REGRETTABLY AT SPECS WE OPPOSE
AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO. ALL RIGHT
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESS NOT LISTED SO DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER- FOLKS I KNOW
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM TO
TESTIFY AGAINST IT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO NEW PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM- NO THE OTHER ROOM STILL
EMPTY SO LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE LINE. TO OPPOSE
AB. SEVEN THREE TWO. ANYONE ON
THE LINE. TO OPPOSE AB SEVEN
THREE TWO. OPERATOR LET'S CHECK
OUT IF YOU'D LIKE TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD FOR
OPPOSITION AGAIN THAT IS ONE
THEN IT ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP ON THE PHONE. SO I
WILL COLIN CENTER JACKSON IN A
MOMENT. I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR
INTRODUCING THIS I CANNOT
BELIEVE THAT IN- I FIRST
INTRODUCED A BILL AROUND
SHACKLING OF PREGNANT WOMEN IN-
JAILS AND PRISONS YEAH BACK IN
I THINK WAS TO THE NINE. AND
YET WE STOPPED THE PRACTICE
AND- YOU KNOW WE WOULD NOT NEED
TO DO THE START THE STATUTES
IF. OUR COUNTY JAILS WE'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING AND
ADOPTED THEIR OWN APPROPRIATE
REGULATIONS WE KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT PREGNANCY THAT. THERE'S
MANY MANY POSSIBLE
COMPLICATIONS THAT ARE NOT IN
ANY WAY EVIDENT JUST LOOKING AT
THE PREGNANT INDIVIDUAL THINGS
LIKE HI SURE RIGHT IF THINKS
THAT I. NUMBER CAN COMPLICATE
THAT PREGNANCY AND CREATE VERY
BAD OUTCOMES AND GIVEN. THAT IF
A PERSON IS IN OUR CUSTODY WE
MUST PROVIDE EVERY BIT OF.
APPROPRIATE CARE FOLLOWING ALL
THE MEDICAL GUIDELINES AND I
DON'T THINK I COULD FIND ONE
MEDICAL DOCTOR WHO WOULD TELL
YOU THAT IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO
SHACKLE A PREGNANT WOMAN. HELLO
I'M GLAD OF IT BEFORE AGAIN I
HOPE THAT IT WILL FINALLY BE
NOT ONLY ENACTED BUT SIGNED
INTO LAW AND WE DON'T HAVE TO
DISCUSS THIS SINCE IT'S NOW
GOING ON FOR ME ELEVEN YEARS
SENATOR JACKSON'S. WELL HI
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
CHAIR AND TOO GOOD THING THAT
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ISN'T IN
THIS FORUM. AT THE MOMENT WE'VE
HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS BEFORE
WITH THE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
THE LACK OF RESPECT. THE
ABSENCE OF ANY SEMBLANCE OF
DIGNITY. THAT THESE WOMEN
EXPERIENCE IS CHARGED ON
ACCEPTABLE IN TODAY'S WORLD
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE AS I
WAS LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY.
THE NOTION THAT WOMEN ARE
SHACKLED DURING PREGNANCY THE
NOTION THAT THEY ARE TREATED
WITH SUCH DISDAIN AND
HUMILIATION. AND THAT WE NOW
ACTUALLY HAVE THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OBJECTING. TO
LEGISLATION THAT WILL PROHIBIT
SHACKLING THAT WILL PROHIBIT
THE POLICIES THAT ARE
CONTINUING TO BE CONDUCTED. OUR
JAILS IS ABSOLUTELY APPALLING
TO ME. AND FRANKLY DISGRACEFUL.
AND I ASKED MYSELF HOW MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE IN THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ARE WOMEN WHO HAVE
EVER GIVEN BIRTH. BECAUSE YOU
HAVE ARE. WHAT THAT EXPERIENCES
LIKE AND YOU SHOULD NOT BE IN A
POSITION WHERE YOU CAN
HUMILIATE AND DEGRADE WOMEN
GOING THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE
AND THEN COME TO THIS PLACE AN
OBJECT TO SOME OF THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS OF HUMAN
DIGNITY. THIS BILL CALLS FOR.
THIS BILL DOESN'T ASK THAT
THESE PEOPLE BE TREATED AS
ANYTHING OTHER THAN HUMAN
BEINGS. PREGNANT WOMEN GIVING
BIRTH A NEW OPPOSE THIS. YOU
SHOULD BE ASHAMED. AND I AM
EMBARRASSED FOR THIS
ORGANIZATION AND SO SHOULD YOU
BE WITHOUT I WILL MOVE THIS
BILL. ANY TO A CENTER UNTIL THE
TO LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT I'D
LIKE TO CLOSE VERY AUDREY
MINIMAL OUT HIS ME OF SENATOR
MORE NON MORE LIKE YOU GO AHEAD.
I'M. I GUESS I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- PROVIDE THE
WHOLE PICTURE THAT MAYBE THERE
WERE SOME. JAILS AT WORK.
OPERATING AS WELL AS THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND I DON'T
KNOW. IF THAT IN FIRST AT ALL
JAILS ALL FIFTY COUNTY ARE ARE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE SURE OF SIR.
NOT PROVIDING THE DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THAT IS NECESSARY AT
THIS CRITICAL TIME SIDE. BUT
SHOULD BE CAREFUL THAT. WE
DON'T BLAST THE WHOLE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WHEN MAYBE. THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE- HAVE JUST
ACTION POLICIES IN PLACE SO I.
I JUST WHEN IT WHEN IT SAY THAT
MADAM CHAIR BECAUSE- CENTER
JACKSON I. HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE WAY MAYBE ONE MENTAL
INSTITUTION WAS NOT DOING WHAT
WHICH POST READER. THAN ALL OF
THEM WERE CLOSED AND NOW WE- A
MASSIVE POPULATION ON OUR
STREETS ARE. I JUST WANNA BE
CAREFUL. AND SAY THANK YOU TO
THE SHERIFF'S THAT ARE. DOING A
GOOD JOB IN FEEL THIS IS A
NECESSARY OFFENDED THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE BEING. IMPLICATED OR
THAT THEY ARE DOING THE JOB-
AND I AND I APPOINTED A WOMAN
SURE OF IN THE- SO- SO I JUST
WANT TO. JUST GIVE IT IN IF I
MAY CLARIFY. I THINK YOU. HAVE
SENATOR MORE LOCKERS FINISH TO
NOT TAKE YOUR MANAGER I JUST
WANT TO RESPOND TO THIS
JACKSON. YEAH MY POINT WAS NOT
AS I SHOULD THE ASSOCIATION.
WHICH HAS COME BEFORE US TODAY
IN OPPOSITION SHOW THE WITNESS
WAS REPRESENTING THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I AM SURE. THERE
ARE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE CONDUCTING THEMSELVES IN A
MUCH MORE HUMANE MANNER. BUT MY
POINT MY COMMENTS WERE DIRECTED
AT THIS ASSOCIATION THE CAME
BEFORE US TODAY OBJECTING ON
THE GROUNDS THAT WERE SET FORTH
THAT THAT'S THE POINT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR ENOUGH I WASN'T CLEAR
MY APOLOGIES. IT IS THE FACT
THAT THIS ASSOCIATION HAS
REGISTERED FORMAL OPPOSITION
AND TO FIGHT HERE TODAY. IN
OPPOSITION THAT IS THE
INITIATION THAT'S THE ENTITY
THAT I WAS CALLING OUT NOT
INDIVIDUAL SURE UPS AND IT IS
MY HOPE THAT IF THERE ARE
INDIVIDUAL SHERIFFS WHO SHARE
MY EMBARRASSMENT THAT THIS
ORGANIZATION COME OUT IN
OPPOSITION AND ART CHELATED
ITSELF SUCH THE DAY BIG GAP AND
IT IS HOPED THAT THE- FORWARD.
THE SURE SHOWS ASIAN ARM. ITS
ROLE ALL SO GIVING PEOPLE THEIR
DIGNITY SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN.
BRADFORD YOU HAVE COMMON. I WAS
JUST GONNA THAT WHICH AS SOON
JOHN AND STATED I DON'T THINK
SHE WAS CASTING ASPERSIONS ON
ANY PARTICULAR BUT AS AN
ASSOCIATION AND YOU COME OUT IN
OPPOSITION TO. HUMANE
TREATMENT. I THINK IT'S THE
OBLIGATION OF THAT ASSOCIATION
THEN TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR MEMBERS WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS. AND ASKS WHY ARE THE
OPPOSING HUMANE TREATMENT
BECAUSE I CAN ASSURE YOU IF MEN
WERE GIVEN BIRTH THEY WOULD BE
TREATED IN THE SAME FASHION.
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA I WOULD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN RESPONSE TO ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES QUESTION. IS THIS
A PROBLEM OF ONE BAD JAIL- LET
ME CLEAR FIVE THAT TO- THERE
HAD BEEN SOME ISSUES AND A FEW
COUNTIES WHICH I'M NOT GONNA
NAME HERE BUT- IT'S CLEAR THAT
A STATEWIDE SOLUTIONS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE QUALITY
REPRODUCTIVE CARE YOU RECEIVE
SHOULDN'T DEPEND UPON WHERE YOU
HAPPEN TO BE ARRESTED IN WHERE
YOU'RE INCARCERATED. SO WE
STATEWIDE SOLUTION- IS
IDENTIFIED AS THE AS THE
PREFERRED A TWENTY SIXTEEN
REPORT BY THE ACLU ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE IN CAT
CALIFORNIA COUNTY JAILS.
DOCUMENTED NUMEROUS ABUSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. INCLUDING
REQUIRING WOMEN TO GET
PREGNANCY TESTING- WHEN THEY
DIDN'T WANT THEM. FORCING A
WOMAN REQUESTED AN ABORTION TO
WAIT TWO MONTHS FOR THE
PROCEDURE PUSHING HER IN A AT
HER SECOND TIME TRIMESTER. JAIL
STAFF ENCOURAGING SOME PREGNANT
WOMEN TO GET ABORTIONS WHEN
THEY DID NOT WANT THEM. PUTTING
A WOMAN WHO WAS DESPONDENT WHEN
RETURNING TO JAIL AFTER HAVING
GIVEN BIRTH. AND THE ANSWER FOR
HER BABY INTO THE HOLE SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR THREE DAYS POST
PARTUM. FORCING A WOMAN WHO HAD
JUST GIVEN BIRTH TO WALK
UPSTAIRS TO AN UPPER TIER SALE.
SO THOSE ARE SOME SPECIFIC
CONCRETE EXAMPLES THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN COUNTY JAILS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- I THINK
THAT SAY- ARE SIMILAR TO THE
WHAT ANGELICA'S PARTS.
TESTIMONY SENATOR SKINNER YOU
KNOW MY EXPERIENCE GOES BACK
WITH THIS I HAD TO DO MY OWN
MATH HERE THIRTY THREE YEARS AS
A STAFFER HERE TO THE SENATE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WHEN THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. VISITED CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN. AND I
WOULD SUGGEST- THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WHO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT COST IT PERHAPS UNFUNDED
MANDATE TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR-
BROTHER SISTER ORGANIZATION THE
STATE PRISON SYSTEM AND LOOK AT
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS LOST IN
LAWSUITS. WHERE WOMEN SUED FOR
INAPPROPRIATE- FROM FOR ABUSE
DURING CHILDBIRTH AND ONE. CAN
SELECT THEIR CONCERN IS A
FISCAL ONE I WOULD SUGGEST-
OUNCE OF PREVENTION MIGHT WORK-
PRE VITAMIN A PRENATAL VITAMINS
ARE PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR.
ALLOWING SOMEONE TO HELP LOWER
BLOOD VERSUS THE UPPER BUNK HAS
NO COST ALLOCATIONS. AND SO IF
THERE CAN. IS TAKE A LOOK AT
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PAID
OUT BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO PREGNANT WOMEN WHO
EXPERIENCED ABUSE IN THE STATE
FACILITY WHICH IS WHY. ON AT
DATE. WE KNOW HAVE THESE
ISSUES. ON THE FACT THAT WE ARE
DEBATING. THE APPROACH TO
SHACKLE SOMEONE TO A BED OR
BELLY CHAIN SOMEONE IN
TRANSPORT TO DELIVER A BABY IN
TWENTY TWENTY- IS BEYOND THE
PALE. YOU KNOW THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I BELIEVE IS A
DEMOCRATIC BODY THAT SURE
EXCEPT TO VOTE AND MAKE A
DECISION ON THE POSITION THEY
TAKE ON BILLS AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT ON THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SHERIFF'S ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
WHO PERHAPS ARE MALE UNDERSTAND
THEIR LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
PROVIDING CARE AND HEALTH
DELIVERY SERVICES TO ALL
INMATES WITHIN THEIR CUSTODY BE
THEY MALE OR FEMALE WITH THAT-
MADAM CHAIR ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- SENATOR
MITCHELL THAT IS A MOTION OF DO
YOU PASS TO APPROACH SEND.
MINORITY SPOKE BUT BEFORE WE
TAKE THE VOTE EVEN THOSE
COUNTIES THAT. MAY FEEL THAT
THEY HAVE A GOOD RULE OR GOOD
DRUG GOOD PRACTICES HAVE FALLEN
SHORT IN MY OWN COUNTY. THERE
WAS A WOMAN WHO IS PUT IN THE
HOLE WHO IS PREGNANT WHO THEY
FELT- PERHAPS FOR A
DISCIPLINARY REASONS. AND SHE
ENDED UP GIVING BIRTH ALONE
WHILE SHE WAS IN THAT SOLITARY
CELL. AFTER A REPORTEDLY
CALLING OUT MULTIPLE TIMES AND
HAVING NO ONE RESPOND AND SO
SHE WAS LEFT THERE AND THEY DID
NOT- THEY FOUND HER LATER. IN
THE CELL. WITH THE NEWLY BORN
CHILD SO EVEN IN THOSE COUNTIES
THAT REPORTEDLY HAVE ADOPTED
GOOD PROCEDURES ARE PRACTICES
WE FIND THESE ARE. ACTUALLY
INEXCUSABLE CIRCUMSTANCES SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROACH HIM WE WILL DO A
ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO
BONTA DEPRESSED APPROPRIATION
MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR
JACKSON'S SKINNER. FIVE IN OUR
AYE MORLOCK. MORE LIKE NOT
VOTING BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON JACKSON I AM
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL ARI MORALE.
SENATOR MORRELL HELP MORALE
NARROW WIENER WIENER HI. THE
MUCH. PASSES FIVE ONE EIGHT
TIMES CHAU WE WILL NOW GO. TO
WE WILL NOW GO TO FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE
WHICH IS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM'S BILL AND PERHAPS
OF A- PERHAPS- THE- OUR PHONE
OPERATORS CAN JUST ANNOUNCE
THAT IT IT'LL BE IN VERY FEW
MINUTES THAT WE WILL BE TAKING
THE PHONE- SO WE WILL GO TO IT
UNTIL THE PRESENTATIONS
FINISHED BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF THE CALLERS
KNOW THAT WERE ON AB. FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE. OKAY GREAT OKAY
ALRIGHT GO AHEAD US SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM OF CALL
SOME PRESENT A ALL OF SUBMIT A
REFER NINETY NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AB
FIFTY NINETY NINE WILL REQUIRE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
COMPLETE ALL- LAW ENFORCEMENT
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS. AND
TO COME TO A FINDING AND THE
PUBLICLY RELEASE THEIR FNDINGS
AND THEY WILL HAVE TO DO SO
EVEN IF THE LAWN OFFICER. HAS
RESIGNED- LAUGHED- THE AGENCY.
AS WE KNOW LAST YEAR- THE CHAIR
AUTHORED SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION-
TO ALLOW FOR THE RELEASE OF
CERTAIN PERSONNEL RECORDS-
RELATING TO- CLAIMS OF
MISCONDUCT. UNFORTUNATELY THERE
IS A LOOPHOLE. IN THE CODE THAT
ALLOWS POLICE OFFICERS TO NOT
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE WHEN
THEY'RE ACCUSED OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT SUCH AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT. WORD FIVE FIVE
MISCONDUCT RELATED DEADLY
FORCE. THEY CAN SIMPLY RESIGN
AND THE INVESTIGATION AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
COMMENCES LEGISLATION- BECAUSE
OF THE SITUATION AND SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY PART OF HIS
DISTRICT. ARE WARY FORMER
POLICE SERGEANT CHRISTOPHER
ACQUIRE WAS ACCUSED OF MULTIPLE
COUNTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
EVERY TO HIS RISE. BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION WAS COMPLETED. ON
THOSE RECORDS WERE NEVER
RELEASED EXCUSE ME TO THE
PUBLIC. THIS IS THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY AND ALSO FEEDS AND TO
THE SYSTEM WE HAVE WERE POLICE
OFFICERS ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT
LEAVE AN AGENCY. NEVER GOT
FOUND GUILTY OF MISCONDUCT AND
I GET HIRED SOMEWHERE ELSE
WHICH HUGE. PUBLIC SAFETY RISKS
HI THIS LEGISLATION WILL CLOSE
IT WILL A LOOPHOLE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER LET'S
GO TO OUR LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT THAT'S BRITNEY BAR
SAUDI OF THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS IF
OUR STUDY- REPRESENT IN
CALIFORNIANS VIEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE- AS- NOTED
I SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE BY AND
YOUR SKINNER. ALLOW FOR IT OUT
FOR THE- THE DISPOSABLE WHEN
THEY'RE COLORS HELLO ACTUAL.
ONE HEY THE MISCONDUCT BY
OFFICERS I'M FORTUNATE THE AN
ANOMALY THAT WHEN ALL WITH OR
RESIGN PRIOR TO THE COMPLETE OF
INVESTIGATION FOR THE OLDER
DECLINE HE DAIS AID OF THE
INFORMATION TO THEIR LEISURE
CONDUCT. FIFTEEN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINE. HAM CLOSE
THE LOOPHOLE AND WILL PROTECT
THE PUBLIC AND ENSURE THAT
THESE TAPES THE ALLEGATIONS ARE
DISCLOSED FALL UNDER THE HEALTH
PUBLIC RECORDS I RESPECTFULLY
DRIVER. THANK YOU ARE DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. ALRIGHT SO LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANY- WITNESSES IN
THIS NOT IN THIS ROOM- LET'S
SEE IF THE OTHER ROOM IS STILL
MTS OKAY SO LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO IS CALLING
ON THE LINE AB FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR. IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO GET
INTO THE QUEUE ON THE PHONE
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT THAT CLAIMED THREE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MIKE A DOCTOR
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE LINE
TWO NINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
BANNEKER O'DONNELL ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX
LINE FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. AND IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORTING YOU'D LIKE
TO GET INTO THE QUEUE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE ELSE IN THE PHONE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S A OF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO LEAD
LISTED SO WE'LL JUST GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE CALLING IN TO
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE.
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE KEY PAD
AGAIN ONE AND ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE KEYPAD IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING UP ON THE PHONE AT THIS
TIME- LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. GO AHEAD SENATOR
JACKSON'S. I APOLOGIZE I'M A
LITTLE UNCLEAR THE- IS I
UNDERSTAND IT THIS FOR THIS
MEASURE REQUIRES AN AGENCY THAT
CONDUCTS AN INVESTIGATION TO
DISCLOSE ITS FINDINGS. NO LATER
THAN OF THE CLOSE TO THE
INVESTIGATION. TO WHOM ARE
THESE FINDING SUPPOSED TO BE
DISCLOSED. SENATOR WIENER I CAN
PROBABLY ANSWER THAT. IF YOU
WOULD IT'S AN AMENDMENT TO THE-
TO THE PROVISIONS THAT WERE IN
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SO IT IS
JUST A TIMING ISSUE OF WHEN THE
RECORDS COULD BE AVAILABLE SO
IN OTHER WORDS. THE. THE IN IT
THIS BILL ONLY AFFECTS THOSE
RECORDS THAT WERE MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE. SO IT- WHAT IT WHAT
IT PROVIDES FOR IS THAT. ONCE
THE- INVESTIGATION IS CONCLUDED
THAT THEN OF COURSE ANY RECORDS
REQUEST WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE RECORDS AND THE PROBLEM
HERE IS. IF YOU HAVE AN OFFICER
WHO RESIGNED AIMS TO IN ORDER
TO TERMINATE THE INVESTIGATION
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENS IN IRAQ.
RECORDS NEVER GOT RELEASED
BECAUSE IT WAS NEVER CONCLUSION.
TO THE INVESTIGATION AND
SERVICE FOR CHOIR THE AGENCY TO
CONTINUE THE INVESTIGATION EVEN
IF THEY'RE OFFICER RESIGNS
COMPLETE THE INVESTIGATION AND
THEN THOSE BECOME DIFFICULT
PLAN OF THE CRITERIA PUBLIC
RECORDS PUBLIC RECORDS OKAY
VERY GOOD THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT IT WAS NOT
CLEAR BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY. IF THE
PERSON AND GOES TO A NEW
EMPLOYER- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE INFORMATION BE READILY
ACCESSED AND THERE IS. SEVERAL
THAT SENT TO BROWN. IS PURSUING
TO ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE BUT THIS WILL BE HELPFUL
NOT JUST FOR SUBSEQUENT
AGENCIES- BUT ALSO FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THANK YOU. THE
FIVE. THESE SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE ARE BILL THAT PROVIDED FOR
THE RECORDS DID NOT ON I
WOULDN'T SAY IT DIDN'T
ANTICIPATED JUST DID NOT
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF THE
POTENTIAL FOR OFFICERS TO LEAVE
AN AGENCY PRIOR TO- AN
INVESTIGATION OR EVEN BEFORE
ONE BEGAN SO THIS IS TO CORRECT
THAT I ALSO HAVE A BILL IN THIS
SECTION SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
WHICH WOULD CORRECT IT FURTHER.
INSURER THAT ANY RECORDS ON AN
OFFICER WHO LEFT IN AGENCY
FOLLOWS THEM AND GOES TO THE
NEXT AGENCY SO ENDED ALSO
EXPANDS WHAT CATEGORIES THAT
OUR RECORDS MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
BUT IT DEALS WITH THIS- ON A
PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN AYE
DEFIED THAT SOMETIMES EIGHTY
AGENCY WILL COME TO AGREEMENT
WITH AN OFFICER TO BE ABLE TO
LEAVE THEIR POSITION. AND THE-
EITHER A DISCIPLINE IS NOT
FULLY COMPLETED OR
INVESTIGATIONS NOT COMPLETED
AND THUS A RECORD IS NOT-
EITHER DOES GO TO THE NEXT
AGENCY OR AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC SO THIS BILL CORRECTS A
CERTAIN VERSION OF IT AND THEN-
I HAVE A BILL SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX THAT WOULD CORRECT ADDITION
PERSONS AND CENTER BRADFORD HAS
A BILL THAT IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN RECORDS IT DEALS
WITH SCEPTRE. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ARE FROM MEMBERS.
RIGHT SEEING NINE WE HAVE A WE
HAVE I BELIEVE WE HAVE MOTION
DID I HEAR MOTION ALMOST ALL
RIGHT TO SENATOR JACKSON HAS
MOVED. AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE.
TO AND THE MOTION WOULD BE TO
DO PASSED TO A PROBES- SENATOR-
WIENER DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
QUESTION I WROTE. ALRIGHT SO
LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE CUNNINGHAM
SKINNER HI IN OUR AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD. EDWARD
I'D JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
IT'S THE EIGHTY OUR STAINED
WIENER. WIENER AYE THE BILL OF
RIGHTS THAT OF BILLS OUT THE
VOTE IS SIX ZERO. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO BILLS AB FIFTY
NINETY NINE SO WE WILL NOW GO
TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE BY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO SENATOR JACKSON WILL
P. WILL BE PRESENTING THIS IS
A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
SORRY WHAT DO I DO. FLORA RHIM
APOLOGIES SORRY. BURGER THAT'S
RIGHT NO WE NEED TO BECAUSE OF
THEIR WITNESSES APOLOGIES. YEAH
WE ALL DO ALRIGHT SO I SKIPPED
ITEM TEN I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
COUNT SO WE'RE GOING TO FILE
ITEM TEN WHICH IS AB NINETEEN
FIFTY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM
LONGER WHICH SENATOR MITCHELL
IS PRESENTING. GO AHEAD SENATOR
MITCHELL. AND THIS IS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR I'M PRESENTING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER AB NINETEEN FIFTY THIS
BILL IS ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILLS IT WOULD SET A
MAXIMUM PROBATION PERIOD OF ONE
YEAR FOR MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES
AND TWO YEARS FOR SOME FELONY
OFFENSES. THE BILL EXEMPTS
CRIMES COMMITTED AGAINST
MONETARY PROPERTY VALUED AT
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ANY SPECIFIC CRIMES
OF PROBATION TERM LINKS
IDENTIFIED BY STATUTE WHICH
INCLUDE THE WISE AND STRIKE
FELONY OFFENSES. MANY SEX
CRIMES ARE IN ELIGIBLE FOR
PROBATION BY STATUTE UNDER
CURRENT PENAL CALLED. THESE ARE
ALSO EXAM. UNDER THIS BILL AB
NINETEEN FIFTY CREATES
REASONABLE AN EVIDENCE BASE
LIMITS ON PROBATION TERMS WHILE
LOWERING COSTS TO TAXPAYERS
ALLOWING FOR THE POSSIBLE
INVESTMENT OF SAVINGS AND A FOR
MEASURES PROVEN TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND INCREASED PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY OFFERS A SLIDING
SCALE APPROACH SUPPORTING
SUCCESS OVER PUNISHMENT. IT
RETAINSJUDICIAL DISCRETION AND
RECOGNIZES THAT PROBATION CAN
STILL BE REVOKED FOR
SUBSTANTIVE VIOLATIONS THE
STATUS QUO HAVE TO CHANGE
PROBATION IS RACIAL CULTURAL
REGIONAL CLASS BASED AN
ARBITRARY CRIPPLING SUB
CULTURES AND ECONOMIES ACROSS
THE STATE. HAITIAN. IS A
GENERATIONAL CURSE IT THE BILL
OF SPELL A CHILD HAS TO WATCH
HIS OR HER MOTHER IN DOING THE
FRUSTRATION OF FIGURED OUT
WHERE TO LIVE AND WHERE TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT ALL WITH ADDITIONAL
LIMITATIONS THAT MAKE THESE
TASKS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT THAN
THEY ALREADY ARE. AND YOUR
PROBATION IS ALSO THE MOST
WIDELY USED FORM OF
CORRECTIONAL CONTROL IN THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S A
SUPERVISED PROBATION POPULATION
IS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND IT'S ONE OF
THE LARGEST IN THE NATION MORE
THAN TWICE THE SIZE OF THE
STATE'S PRISON POPULATION.
ALMOST FOUR TIMES LARGER THAN
THE JAIL POPULATION AND SIX
TIMES LARGER THAN ITS PAROLE
POPULATION. A CLOG THE COURTS
MORE THAN ANY OTHER FORM OF
SUPERVISION. A PROBATION TERM
MAY REQUIRE THAT YOU
CONTINUOUSLY SEEK TO MAINTAIN
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT YOUR ABILITY
TO TRAVEL ACROSS COUNTY LINES
MAY BE RESTRICTED OR YOU MAY BE
SUBMITTED TO A SEARCH OF YOUR
PERSONAL HOME WITHOUT WARNING.
YOU MAY BE IN VIOLATION OF YOUR
TERMS IF YOU'RE LATE OR YOU
MISS AN APPOINTMENT IN IRAQ
WITH A FRIEND OR FAMILY MEMBER
RIGHT IN THE FRONT SEAT OF A
CAR OR GET PREGNANT. BEING ON
PROBATION CAN FEEL LIKE LIVING
IN QUICKSAND. PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS MICRO MANAGE PEOPLE
AND APPLY HAPHAZARD RULES
DESIGNED TO IT EVIDENTLY CATCH
PEOPLE COMMITTING CRIMES.
CRIMES THAT PEOPLE NOT ON
PROBATION WOULDN'T THINK TWICE
ABOUT. 20% OF PRISON ADMISSIONS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE RESULT OF
SUPERVISED PROBATION VIOLATIONS
THE STATE SPENDS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO INCARCERATE
PEOPLE FOR SUPERVISION
VIOLATIONS. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
PROBATION SERVICES SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
ADDICTION TREATMENT ARE MOST
AFFECTED DURING THE FIRST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF SUPERVISION
PROVIDE AN INCREASE THE
PROVISION AND SERVICES EARLIER
REDUCES AN INDIVIDUAL'S
LIKELIHOOD TO RESET OF EIGHT.
THE LONGER PROBATION TERM THE
MORE EXPENSIVE IT IS FOR
TAXPAYERS. AND LESS EFFECTIVE.
AND THAT THOSE WHO COMMITTED NO
CRIME DO SO WITHIN THE FIRST
TWO YEARS WHERE THEY CAN BE
CHARGED. THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
IMPETUS FOR COUNTIES TO
REDESIGN PROBATION PROGRAMS
BASED ON PRESUMING SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES RATHER THAN COUNTING
ON FAILURES. COUNTY LIKE CONTRA
COSTA AND STATES LIKE LOUISIANA
AND MICHIGAN ARE ALREADY
RETHINKING PROBATION. JUDGES
HAVE CHOSEN TO LOWER PROBATION
TERMS TO TWO YEARS PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS HAVE FRONT LOADED
TREATMENT AND SERVICES AND I'VE
BEEN MORE ROBUST AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO TREATMENT
RATHER THAN THE GOTCHA
APPROACHES THAT VIOLATIONS-
EVOKE. AND THEY'RE NOT DOING
THIS BECAUSE THEY ARE STATE
CERTAINLY THAT ARE CONSDERED
SOFT ON CRIME THEY ARE
REFORMING PROBATION BECAUSE THE
COSTS AND FAILURE RATES ARE TOO
HIGH. THEY ARE REFORMING
PROBATION BECAUSE THEY DECIDED
TO STOP BLAMING PEOPLE ON
PROBATION AND START LOOKING AT
THE SYSTEM ITSELF. YOU CAN
ACHIEVE A LOT IN ONE OR TWO
YEARS WITH ROBUST PROGRAMMING
IN REAL MASHABLE'S ONE YEAR TWO
YEARS CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE TERM.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SAYS THE
PROBATION OFFICERS RATHER THAN
KIOSKS SHOULD BE GUIDING
PROBATIONERS THROUGH TREATMENT.
RISK IN NEED ASSESSMENT TOOL
SHOULD BE REGULARLY USED IN
ADJUSTED FEWER PEOPLE ON
PROBATION MEANS A LIGHTER BUT
POTENTIALLY MORE INTENSIVE
CASELOADS FOR OFFICES CAN FOCUS
QUALITY TIME TO RESOURCES. ON
THEIR CLIENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHALLENGES US TO ENVISION A NEW
NORMAL WHERE JUSTICE IS
RESTORATIVE AND REHABILITATIVE
ROOTED IN RESEARCH FACTS AND
FIGURES. AND A CONSCIOUSNESS
THAT THE WAY WE'VE BEEN DOING
THINGS IS REALLY IN SUFFICIENT.
A NEW NORMAL WERE SUPERVISION
IS NOT ABOUT HOW LONG SOMEONE'S
TERMINUS BUT RATHER THE QUALITY
OF THEIR EXPERIENCE AND HOW
MEANINGFUL IT IS- WE HAVE
SEVERAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REPRESENTS FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE ON AS WELL AS THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU A CENTER MICH FOR
PRESENTING WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE NOW FOR OUR FIRST
LEAD WITNESS A WHICH I BELIEVE
IS WINDY STILL CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING ARE
HONORABLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WHEN IT'S
STILL AND I'M TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY
TODAY AS A CRIMINOLOGIST. AND
BASED UPON APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
YEARS WORKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
INCLUDING EXPERIENCE AS AN
ADMINISTRATOR CREATING RESPONSE
EVERY. REENTRY PROGRAMS FOR
INMATES AND OVER NINE YEARS
EXPERIENCE AS THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER PREVIOUSLY
FOR EXAMPLE DOES GO AND NOW
ALAMEDA COUNTY. CERTAINLY
DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER
EIGHTY FOUR HUNDRED ADULT
PROBATIONERS AB NINETEEN FIFTY
IS AN IMPORTANT BEGINNING TO
REFORM ACT REFORMING COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS PROBATION
SUPERVISION LENGTH WHICH
ROUTINE BY STATUTE OR IMPOSED
IN A STANDARD THREE YEAR OR
OVER SUPERVISION TERMS
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
CRIME. RESEARCH PROVES THAT THE
DURATION OF PROBATION
SUPERVISION TERM IS NOT THE
DETERMINING FACTOR IN THE
SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF THE
PROBATIONER THE QUALITY AND
TYPE OF SUPERVISION OUR SYSTEM
OF SUPERVISION BASED UPON THE
DIRECT LINKAGE TO PROGRAMS
SERVICES AND TREATMENT. THE
CLIENT OFFICER RELATIONSHIP AND
THE DOSAGE OF PROGRAMMING ARE
THE FACTORS THAT INCREASE OR
DIMINISH THE INDIVIDUAL SUCCESS
COMES TO PROVISION. ALSO
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THERE YEARS
EXPERIENCE WHILE AN INDIVIDUAL
IS ON PROBATION SUPERVISION CAN
INCREASE A PROBATIONER CHRIS
CAN TELL YOUR AB NINETEEN FIFTY
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
RESHAPING COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
RECOGNIZING THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE SUPERVISION OF
MISDEMEANOR RECKLESS FELONY
CRIME. THERE ARE SOME
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES WHICH DO
NEED INCREASED SUPERVISION
AREAS AS AN EXAMPLE THOSE
RELATED TO THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HER ELDER OR CHILD
ABUSE WELL THE MAJORITY OF
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES DO NOT. MANY
FELONY CRIMES ALSO DO NOT NEED
A STANDARD THREE YEAR OVER
SUPERVISION TERM HOWEVER SOME
CRIMES DO CALL FOR LONGER THE
PROVISION TERM TEXAS.
ENVIRONMENT FELONY CRIMES
ASSOCIATED WITH PENAL CODE SIX
SEVEN POINT FIVE NEED LONGER
THREE YEARS. TERMS AB FIFTY
EIGHT NINETEEN FIFTY RECOGNIZES
AND ADDRESSES THE DIFFERENCE
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS UNDER PROBATION
SUPERVISION WILL PROVIDE
OFFICERS WITH MORE TIME TO WORK
WITH CLIENTS. PHILIPPINE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLANS AND ENABLE
OFFICERS CONNECT FINANCE WITH
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND OTHER IMPORTANT
SERVICES QUICKLY AND PROVIDING
THE INDIVIDUALIZED CLIENT
SUPPORT NEEDED WHICH WILL
GREATLY IMPROVE THE SUCCESS A
PROBATIONER AND ALSO REDUCE
VICTIMIZATION AB NINETEEN FIFTY
WILL ALSO SUPPORT PROBATION
OFFICER. AND COMPLAINING TO THE
DUTIES THEIR JOB MORE
EFFECTIVELY BY REDUCING AND
MAKING THEIR CASE LOADS MORE
MANAGEABLE IN TWENTY TEN THE
LEGISLATURE. ENACTED AND EIGHT
EVIDENCE BASED PRO SUPERVISION
AND ALLOW A LIKE A ENACTED A
ONE NINE PUBLIC WE- THESE ARE
BOTH MILE WITH OF THE- CHEN
THAT. AB NINETEEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO IMPLEMENT THE NEXT MILESTONE
REFORM THAT WILL CREATE A NEW
NORMAL WITH THE PROVISION IS
NOT A HOW LONG SOMEONE'S TERM
IS. BUT RATHER ABOUT HOW
MEANINGFUL IN. REMAIN
EXPERIENCING. IT IS COULD THAT
TIME ALONG WITH REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF INTO DOING OUT OF
TIME AND- YOUR RESOURCES
PROVIDE BY AND SIX. EIGHT IS
NOT ONLY GIVE OUT OF TO READ.
WE'RE OP. FOR CROWD OF TIME
OPERATE PLEASE IT THERE'S
ANOTHER LEAD WENT YOU'VE USED
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. POLICY I
HAVE STATED THAT ALL. BILLS
ONLY MINUTES TOTAL LEAD AND
THERE'S ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS SO
I'M GOING TO TURN NOW TO THE
NEXT LEAD WITNESS. AND EVEN
THOUGH THE TIME WAS USED UP I'M
GOING TO ALLOW THE NEXT LEAD
WITNESS FORTY FIVE SECONDS
POLICIES GO AHEAD. OF MISTER
RISE YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS A NOTE ARE
SHOWN ON THE ELECTED PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF SAN FRANCISCO A
POLICE TO BE SPEAKING TO YOU
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THAT CAN FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BLOGGER IT'S
TIME TO GET REAL IF. PROBATION
IS WORKING WE SHOULD NEED
EXTENSIVE TIME TO DELIVER THOSE
SERVICES AS PUBLIC DEFENDERS WE
FREQUENTLY SEE FORMER CLIENTS
OF OURS WHO HAVE FOUGHT LONG
AND HARD ALONG SIDE. WE FOUGHT
BARGAIN ARE LONG SET OF TO EARN
THEIR FREEDOM CYCLE BACK INTO
THE SYSTEM SIMPLY DUE TO SOME
TECHNICAL VIOLATION. OF THEIR
PROBATION CONDITIONS- THESE
TECHNICAL CONDITIONS COULD BE
MISSING APPOINTMENT ALTHOUGH
ONE MORE THAN ONE CLIENT OF
MINE HAS TOLD ME THEY TRIED TO
REACH A PROBATION OFFICER.
WHOSE VOTES VOICE MAIL WAS
FULL. TO UNPAID FEINSTEIN NOT
MEETING THESE ARE VIOLATION
PAPER IN ON. WHEN VIOLATIONS
THE HAPPENED. IN THE PROBATION
PERIOD SO THERE'S NO NEED TO
HAVE THAT EXTENSION SECONDLY
PROBE PAROLE AND PROBATION
VIOLATION SPEND A COSTS IN THE
STATE APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. ANNUALLY THE HUGE
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO THE JAIL
TERM PROBLEM IT'S BECOME MUCH
MORE WELL KNOWN ISSUE AND A-
DEEP CONCERN DURING THIS CORONA
VIRUS. TIMES THERE ARE SO MANY
LOW POINTS IN THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM UNFORTUNATELY ONE
OF THE HIGHEST POINTS IS SEEING
CLIENTS SUCCESSFULLY. COMPLETE
THEIR PROBATION AND WE NEED
THOSE POINTS THAT HAPPENED MORE
OFTEN. AND EARLIER BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT OPENS UP PEOPLE TO
REAL REHABILITATION REAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU AND IT
BREAKS DOWN THE BARRIERS OF
HOUSING. THANK YOU THE RESIDUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WILL BE
MORE CLEAR BEFORE THE WITNESSES
START AND I AM GOING TO IT IF
THERE ARE TO LEAD WITNESSES I
WILL CUT THE FIRST OFFICE TWO
MINUTES JUST SO THE NEXT ONE
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE SOME TIME.
AND APOLOGIES THAT WE HAVE TO
DO THIS BUT ITS THE- NATURE OF
IT JUST TAKES LONGER WHEN WE'RE
DOING REMOTE UNDERSTOOD ALL
RIGHT SO- LET US SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE. FIFTY ANYONE HERE ALRIGHT
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE OTHER HEARING ROOM SEEING
NONE THEY WILL DO THE PHONE
LINES FOR AB NINETEEN FIFTY.
OPERATOR YES IF YOU LIKE TO GET
INTO THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU
WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD WE HAVE LINE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD FORTY
TWO. REBECCA LAWLESS NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
BLIND FORTY EIGHT LINE FOR EACH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TYSON AND
FIRST MARQUESS OF CALIFORNIANS
TRONG SUPPORT. IF LINE THIRTY
SIX NINE THREE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
HOLLOW BILL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY THREE LINE SIX THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTY FIVE
LINE SEVEN FIVE. JIM WONDERED
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
IF LINE NUMBER THIRTY EACH LINE
IT'S THREE EIGHT. LIKE A DOCTOR
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE LINE SEVEN
THREE. AB JOBS WITH INITIATE
DOESN'T IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN LINE SEVEN SEVEN.
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWENTY
LINE Q. ZERO. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER SEVENTY
ONE LINE SEVEN ONE. SHE WHIRLED
MARYLAND MORE OFTEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER TWENTY TWO
LINE AT TWO TWO. EMORY ON
BEHALF OF MOMENTUM UNITED IN
STRONG SUPPORT. FINE NUMBER
FIFTY SIX LINE FIVE SIX. LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHY NUMBER FIFTEEN LINE ONE
FIVE. AND MEETING RIGHT HERE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR LINE SEVEN FOUR.
AND YOUR BRIEF SO WE HAVE TO
REFORM ALLIANCE INTO PORT. WHY
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN LINE AT FIVE
SEVEN. HI ELAINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTY SEVEN IF YOU
WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE KEY WE
DO HAVE YOUR LINE OPEN. OKAY I
WILL GO NEXT TO LINE SEVENTY
NINE LINE SEVEN NINE. THIS CAR
IS GOING TO CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE PHONE Q. THANK YOU.
STORIES ARMED WORKS MY GLASSES
ARE FALLING DOWN- ARE WE
HEARING NO OTHER COLLINS FOR
SUPPORT FREE ME NINETEEN FIFTY
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION THE LEAD OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE THAT'S- GOING TO BE
SPEAKING IS. THE PROBATION
CHIEF BRIAN RE CHART FROM THE
PROBATION OFFICERS ARE CORRECT.
YES GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME OKAY
YES YES PROCEED. AND OUT SICK
YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BRIAN RICHARD TO PROBATION
OFFICER PEARL DORADO COUNTY AND
PRESIDENT OF THE TWO
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA- IS HERE
TO DISCUSS THIS MORNING IN OUR
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION-
WE ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SHARE OUR POSITION WITH THE OFF
WE APPRECIATE THAT SHE'S
ENGAGED SYSTEM DIALOGUE- AS TO
THE NATURE OF OUR OPPOSITION-
WHAT THIS BILL CLEARLY
RECOGNIZES IS A SHORT PROBATION
TERMS ARE SMART STEP TOWARD
REFORM AND SHE- REACHED WITH
THAT- BUT WE- HAVE. SUPPORTED
THE GOVERNOR IN THE STATE
BUDGET HE PROPOSED SOMETHING
VERY SIMILAR AND WHAT HE NEED
TO POINT OUT AND OUT TO THE
AUTHOR IS THAT. PERHAPS
LEGISLATION ANGELINA. HARD ACT
ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE FROM
VOTING SERVICE IN AREAS WHERE
WE HAVE LARGELY SO WITH KOBE
OPENED LAST IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THAT IS THE ALL TO INCARCERATE.
ARE WORK ARGUE THIS REALLY
PROVIDE THE PATHWAYS BOTH THE A
BILL PIECE IT'S EXPECT BY THE
CAN AND VICTIMS AT WELL AS THE
P. THAT BE GREEN EXPECTED BY
CLIENTS WHEN THEY COME INTO OUR
WORK ENVIRONMENT THAT THAT'S
OUR MISSION THAT'S OUR FOCAL
POINT IS THAT PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY COMES
THROUGH US HELPING TO HEAL-
PEOPLE THAT COME TO US AS A
RESULT OF THAT THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM- BUT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE ALL MODES
THAT SIDE OF THE CREEK BECOMING
JUST ASSIST. COLOR AND
LOGICALLY THERE WOULD BE. UPS I
SHOULD SAY LIKE A SUPER WILL
DESTROY IN THAT POPPED AS WELL
SHORT TERM THEREFORE LIKELY
IMPROVE THOSE CONDITIONS- BUT
UNDERSTAND PROBATION DOESN'T
CHOOSE WHO WE WORK WITH THEIR
DELIVERED TO US BY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WE DON'T
CHOOSE HOW LONG THEY STAY ON
PROBATION THAT WAS DELIVERED TO
US BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM SO
WHERE IS NEEDED GREED THE
PROBATION BLANKS IN MANY.
INSTANCES BUT IN SHOULD BE
SHORTER WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
FACT THAT WITHOUT THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO FRONT LOAD THE
SYSTEM WITH SERVICES THAT YOU
MAY IN FACT PRODUCE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
CAUSING PEOPLE TO GO DEEPER
INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM BY NOT PROVIDING THE
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THEY NEED. TO SHIFT COURSE
THEY DON'T RECEIVE WHAT THEY
ARE EIGHTEEN ON A LIMITED TIME
FOR THE D. H. NEED TO WRAP UP.
YES PROBATION DOES SPONSORED
FORMS WE REFORM OR OR WE SEE
THIS FOR IS ONE NOT THIS BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE THE SMART AND THE
TO BE DONE A WAY THAT THAT DOES
PROVIDE LAST THIRTY SECONDS FOR
A VIDEO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT NEXT THE KEY WITNESS
CRAP. FROM THE DA ASSOCIATION
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBER IF THE MARKET ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIFTY. A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL PROBATION BECAUSE NOT WORK.
IT TREAT SIMILAR DEFENDED
FAMILIARLY. A DEFENDANT
CONVICTED OF MULTIPLE CRIME OR
FALLING. FOR MULTIPLE VICTIM IS
TREATED EXACTLY THE SAME OF THE
DEFENDANT CONVICTED OF ONLY ONE
CRIME. IF BILL ISN'T A PROBLEM
BUT NOT EXACT. IF THE JUDGE
FEELS THE ONLY TWO YEARS OF
PROBATION IS APPROPRIATE THE
JUDGE IN ORDER. TO YEARS OF
PROBATION UNDER CURRENT LAW HE
SAID REASONS ARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE SO NOW WE WILL.
SEE IF THERE IS ANY COLLINS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN FIFTY
OPERATOR. YOUR IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE GOT A
LINE THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S FINE
THREE EACH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT WE DO HAVE A
ONE OPEN YOU MAY WANT TO CHECK
YOUR MUTE FEATURE. OKAY FIVE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS ALBERTO TO RECALL ME
UP THE STATE COLLECTS
INFORMATION ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
ONE MOMENT WE'RE GETTING A LINE
NUMBER JUST ONE MOMENT. THE ONE
MORE MOMENT THANK YOU. OKAY WE
DO HAVE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT NOT NUMBER
MATTHEWS ONLY HALF THE LAW
ANGELES OFFICERS YOU KNOW YOU
LOOK SIX EIGHTY FIVE ALL NOT
THANK YOU. IN LINE NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE LINE AT FIVE FIVE. I'M
SURE MEMBERS RANGE FROM A WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
AND IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE PHONE
Q. PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU I
DID NOT ASK TO SEE FOR ANYONE
IN THE ROOM BECAUSE THERE WAS.
NO CHANGES IN WHO IS IN THE
ROOM SO- KLAY HERE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. RIGHT
SENIOR AND WE CAN NOW. TURN TO
MY COLLEAGUES IF ANYONE HAS ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. A CENTER
WIENER GO AHEAD I THANK YOU ON
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
KNOW WE FOCUS A LOT ON.
REDUCING OUR PRISON POPULATION
ARE FOR SO MANY REASONS- WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
CALIFORNIA. WITH HIS REPORTED
ONE BACK UNDER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
PRISON SYSTEM FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THIRTY YEARS. FIVE
PROGRESS BUT LET'S REMEMBER
THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY WE HAD
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE.
DIE IN PRISON AND WE RE NOT
ANY SAFER TODAY THAN WE WERE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. FIVE THREE TO
CONTINUE TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
PRISON POPULATIONS AND CLOSE
DOWN PRISONS AND- STOP SPENDING
SO MUCH ON PRISONS BUT THE
OTHER PIECE OF IT IS- PROBATION.
AND WE HAVE- CENTER MENTAL
INDICATED BEGINNING AN ENORMOUS
NUMBER OF PEOPLE. ON PROBATION
AND ALL PROVISION IS NOT. AS
DAMAGING BUT IS INCARCERATION.
IT STILL IS INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE AND IT'S STILL
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTS PEOPLE'S
LIVES. WHEN YOU DREAM MORE
EFFECTIVE ABOUT THIS WE DON'T
NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE INFORMATION
AS LONG AS THEY ARE AND THIS IS
A GOOD DEAL I SUPPORT CENTER
JACKSON. IS AT I AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO REDUCE THE LENGTH OF
TIME I DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE
THE PROBATION IS A BAD THING- I
THINK WHEN IT'S DONE RIGHT TO
AND DONE WELL IT IS VERY VERY
HELPFUL TO PEOPLE. WHO ARE
TRYING TO TRANSIT TRANSITION
BACK INTO NORMAL- LAW ABIDING.
LIFE STYLES AND EXPERIENCE-
I'VE BEEN A CHATTING WITH THE
WITH THE CHI PROBATION OFFICERS
AND BOTH COUNTIES AND IN
PARTICULAR SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
THE- THE FACT THERE IT IS- THAT
THE- SERIOUSLY THAT ANY SERIOUS
PROBATION VIOLATIONS. ARE
LIKELY TO OCCUR- WITHIN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS. ALL OF A
PERSON'S- A PROBATIONARY PERIOD
AND THERE AFTER THE PROBATIONER
ASSEMBLY HAS WHAT ARE FRANKLY
UNNECESSARY IN STRESSFUL
PRESSURES TO COMPLY WITH THESE
LITTLE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
THINGS THAT SEND PEOPLE BACK TO
PRISON WILL HAPPEN FAIRLY
QUICKLY AFTER THEY ARE RELEASED
IT FOR THEIR GONNA HAPPEN AT
ALL AND IN FACT WHAT HAPPENS
SHE IS THAT. THE LENGTH OF
TERMS ARE SO LONG PROBATION
OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN A HUGE NUMBERS TO WHAT
THEY CALL BANKS FILES. THAT
THEY DON'T WORK THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEIR IT IT'S NOT
EFFECTIVE USE OF THEIR TIME.
THERE'S NO ACTIVE SUPERVISION
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU GET A
TRAFFIC TICKET THREE FOUR YEARS
LATER BLOOM. BACK TO
INCARCERATION YOU GO WHICH
WHICH MAKES NO SENSE FRANKLY-
BUT I WAS WONDERING. OUR END
BECAUSE THE AUTHORS IN HERE I
JUST LIKE TO SUGGEST. THAT AT
LEAST FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE FOLKS THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH- THEY'D LIKE TO
CONSIDER AND HAVE US CONSIDER
THE IMPLICATIONS. OF SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT FUNDING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT FUNDING IS
STABILIZE FOR OF THE CHEST
THEIR CASELOAD CHANGES IF THIS
MEASURE PASSES. AND TO MAKE
SURE THEY CAN PROVIDE THAT
TREATMENT AND SUPERVISION
REQUIRED TO BE DELIVERED
QUICKLY ENOUGH DURING THAT
JORDAN SHOULD. PATIENT PERIOD
IN OTHER WORDS THE GOAL HERE IS
SUCCESS. AND IN ORDER TO HAVE
SO THIS TREATMENT PASSED TO
OCCUR FAIRLY QUICKLY UPON
RELEASE AND SO THEY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE. AND IT'S MY
WHOLE BY CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE BUT IT IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT THIS BE SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
IF IT ISN'T WILL KINDA KNEE
JERK BACK TO THE OLD SYSTEM.
SYSTEM WE BELIEVE. IN HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED AROUND THE WORLD
IN IN IN OTHER STATES IN OUR
COUNTRY THOSE WORK. IT DOES
WORK BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
WE IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY
AND EFFECTIVELY SO THAT IT DOES
WORK SO THAT WE DON'TFIND
OURSELVES. FEELING THAT WE HAVE
TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING THAT-
SIMPLY PUTS PEOPLE AWAY AND
WHERE HOUSE SYSTEM AND- GETS
THEM OUT OF OUR IMMEDIATE
VISION. ONLY TO SEE THAT THEY
WILL COME BACK OR THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION WILL COME- THIS
EIGHT. WHEN APPROACH. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RESORT TO THERE
SO CAN BE PROPERLY IMPLEMENTED
SO. BY I WILL ASK THE- AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
TO MAKE SURE THE RESOURCES ARE
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE SO WITH
THIS PROGRAM CAN WORK IN WITH
THAT- I WOULD. HAPPILY AND MOVE
THE BILL. THE CENTER MITCHELL
YOU YOU CAN RESPOND IF YOU
CHOOSE TO BUT YOU KNOW HOW DO
AND I'LL DO INCLUDE YOUR
CLOTHES OKAY I'LL BE PREPARED
TO IN CLOSING OKAY GREAT
SENATOR. WIENER THAT YOU KNOW I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY NOT.
SUGGESTING THAT PROVISION IS
BAD REGION CAN BE DONE AN
EXCELLENT WAY AND SENT US IN
THE STILL USED TO RUN OUR ADULT
PROBATION DEPARTMENT SAN
FRANCISCO. AND IT'S A GREAT
MODEL FOR GIVING PEOPLE ACCESS
A RESOURCE AND SERVICES BASED
MODEL SO- BUT IT CAN BE TOO
LONG. ANY OTHER- YES SENATOR-
MORE LUCK. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I SEE A HOUSE DIVIDED IT
PROBATION OFFICERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ARGUMENT SO I.
BUT ME AND MY- COMMENTARIES I
DON'T SEE ANY. POSITIONS TAKEN
BY THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM. I HAVE
HAD IT HERE HAS YOUR OFFICE
BEEN CONTACTED OLD. OR DESERVE
THE- PRESENTER OF THE BILL HAVE
ANY THE ENDING OF WHAT MAY BE
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES ARE
RECOMMENDING ON THIS PARTICULAR
THING LIKE SIGNIFICATIVA SHARE
YEAH I DIDN'T SEE ANY
REFERENCES IN THE ANALYSIS ANY
AND I CERTAINLY AM NOT IN
RECEIPT OF ANY- OFFICIAL
POSITION THANK YOU. BUT IS THE
GENERAL QUESTION WE COMMONLY DO
HERE FROM THE JUDGES ARE JUDGES
COUNSELING BILLS AND WE DID NOT
ON THE TWENTY. PERHAPS SENATOR
MITCHELL BEFORE I GIVE YOU THE
FLOOR TO CLOSE I WOULD SAY THAT
EVEN WITH GREAT PROGRAMMING.
LONG BLANKS APPROPRIATION TO
NOT SERVE A PERSON SUCCESSFUL
REHABILITATION BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF LIMITATIONS THAT ARE
PUT ON YOU WHEN YOU WERE UNDER
PROBATION AND SO TO SUCCEED IN
BACK FULLY IN RE ENTRY YOU NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET EMPLOYMENT TO
GET EDUCATION TO GET. OUT YOU
KNOW ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WHILE YOU'RE UNDER INFORMATION
IS CONSIDERED SUPERVISION THAT
WHILE YOU'RE UNDERSERVED
SUPERVISION YOU CAN BE
PROHIBITED FROM SO JUST BY ITS
VERY NATURE EVEN UNDER THE BEST
TYPE OF PROGRAM CAN GRAY IN A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO IN FACT
SUCCEED SO I THINK A SHORTENING
IT BEFORE INTENTION IS TO HAVE
PEOPLE. BUT I'D BE FULLY
EMPLOYED IN FULLY SUCCEED IS
VERY VICE BUT- SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE- HEARTY
DIALOGUE AND LET ME START BY
SAYING THAT THE AUTHOR WOULD
ABSOLUTELY AGREE. PROBATION
DONE WELL IS AN APT ENTERED
COMPONENT EVERY ENTRY- SHE
WOULD AGREE- SENATOR JACK FROM
THAT IT'S AN ABSOLUTE ASSET.
AND I AND I'M SURE THEY SHOULD
BE WILLING TO TALK ABOUT THE
FUNDING ISSUE AT A LATER DATE
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR FOR EXAMPLE-
YOU KNOW IN LA COUNTY THE SB
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT DOLLARS
HAVEN'T ALL BEEN SPENT AND SO
PROBABLY IS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THAT FOR
THE MECHANISM TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL COUNTIES ARE SPENDING THOSE
DOLLARS ON THE FRONT IN AN
EFFECTIVE WAY. ABSOLUTELY NOT
HER DESIRE TO REDUCE FUNDING-
SHE WOULD ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT
WITH THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER WHO SPOKE OPPOSITION
THAT IT IS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION BUT THAT IS THEIR
MISSION BUT IF THAT'S THEIR
MISSION WHY ARE WE ALLOWING
MINOR TECHNICAL VIOLATE
VIOLATIONS TO THE ONLY PEOPLE
BACK TO INCARCERATION I THINK
THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS MEASURE
IS TO BE TRUE TO THE TRUE
MISSION AND INTENT AND DESIGN
OF WHAT PROBATION IS ALL ABOUT.
IN RESPONSE TO THE OPPOSITION
FROM THE I'M DIFFICULT
TRANSOCEAN THAT'S TRUE AND
JUDGE CAN ORDER A TWO YEAR OR
LESS PROBATION PERIOD THE POINT
OF THIS BILL IS TO REDESIGN
PROBATION SO THOSE TWO YEARS
ARE SPENT. IN A MEANINGFUL AND
PROFOUND WAY A JUDGE COULD
ORDER TWO YEARS PROBATION NOW
BUT THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
BILL IS TO FRONT LOAD ALL OF
THOSE RESOURCES AND SERVICES.
SAW THOSE TWO YEARS. CAN BE THE
MOST IMPACTFUL THEY ALSO ARGUE
THAT A- A PERSON CAN. IF THEY
FINISH WITH ALL OF THEIR
PROGRAMMING THEY CAN GO BACK TO
THE COURTS TO ASK FOR
TERMINATION. I WOULD QUESTION
THE FREQUENCY WITH WHICH THAT
HAPPENS KNOWING THAT HOW BACKED
UP OUR COURT DOCKETS ARE AND I
WONDER IF PROBATIONERS EVEN
NOW. THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BACK AND TRY
TO SHORTEN YOUR TERM AGAIN IT
MISSES THE POINT THE WHOLE
POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO FRONT
LOAD THE RESOURCES FULL FULL
FULL FIRST TWO YEARS OUR MOST
IMPORTANT. I AGREE WITH YOU
SAID IN A MORE LIKE I DO THINK
IT'S AN INTEREST INTERESTING
THAT THE HOUSE IS DIVIDED. ON
TO HEAR FROM. A BIG COUNTY THE
GALLEY OF ALAMEDA SPEAK FEEL
PASSIONATELY ABOUT HOW THIS
WORKS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT- I
THINK SPEAKS VOLUMES. FOR THE
NEED TO REIMAGINE WE ENVISION
WHAT IT TRULY AFFECTED
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND
EXPERIENCE CAN BE. AGAIN I
THINK THE AUTHOR HAS SHOWN HER
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATION- WITH- OF THOSE IN
OUR POSITIONS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE JUDGES
ARE NEUTRAL. BUT THEY'RE
SUPPORTIVE CERTAIN CAUGHT.
THREE DIED IN THIS NOTION FRONT
LOW REESE. AND DESIGN OF
DEPARTMENT CHILLY MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WHO REALLY.
ISN'T ALL WITH THAT AGAIN I ASK
AND I VOTE. ON A B. NINETEEN
FOR. I WE ARE. FROM JACK. THE
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO A
PRO. SEEING NO OTHER COMMENT WE
WILL. CALL FOR THE ROLE. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THE PASTOR
PREPARATION SKINNER ARE DENIED
MORE LOCK. MORE LIKE NOW WITH
YOUR MICRON CINEMA. YES IT'S ON
NO NO MORE LOVE CANAL. THE HOME
BRADFORD THE CENTER BRADFORD I
NEED YOU TO TURN ON YOUR MAKES.
NOW BRADLEY I MEAN FIVE YES.
MARKET YEAH THAT'S A. SENATOR
JACKSON'S ALL RIGHT SENATE
JACKSON I'D SENATOR WIENER.
WINNER HI I DON'T KNOW WHY
DIFFERENT MITCHELL MITCHELL
HIGH MORALE. SENATOR MORAL NO
ANIMAL NOW. THE VOTERS FIVE TO
THAT- BILL IS OUT EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY IS OUT THE VOTE WAS FIVE
TO. RIGHT NOW WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHOOSE BILL WHICH SENATOR
JACKSON'S IS PRESENTING.
THIRD
THIRD JACKSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
THIS IS A COMMONSENSE MEASURE
IN THE ERA OF TIMES UP IN ME TO
DESIGNATE HUMAN RESOURCE
EMPLOYEES OF ANY BUSINESS WHICH
FROM ALWAYS. YES MANDY
REPORTERS. CALIFORNIA HAS
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
THE WORK FORCE OR AT LEAST WE
DID PRE COVERT. AND HOPEFULLY
WILL AGAIN POST COLD BUT AS
SOON AS WE CAN RESOLVE THAT
CHALLENGE. BUT SADLY THE
WORKPLACE IS ALSO AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND OTHER FORMS OF
EMPLOYEE ABUSE CANNON
FREQUENTLY SADLY TO TAKE PLACE.
RECENT NATIONAL REPORT FOUND
THAT ALMOST ONE THIRD OF THE
EMPLOYMENT COMPLAINTS FILED
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDED AN ALLEGATION OF
HARASSMENT WHEN AN EMPLOYEE
WHEN THE EMPLOYEE IS A MINOR.
AND CONDUCT YOUR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT POLICIES MAY ALSO BE
CHILD ABUSE WHICH MUST
IMMEDIATELY BE REPORTED TO
AUTHORITIES FOR INVESTIGATION.
UNLIKE THE CHILDREN WHO REPORT
CHILD ABUSE IN A SCHOOL SETTING
WHERE TEACHERS AND OTHER
EMPLOYEES RE TRAINED MANDATED
REPORTER. THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
MANDATED FOR WORKING CHILDREN
DIRECTION ANY SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS TO THE HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT. AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE WILL
ENSURE THAT WHEN A REPORT OF
SEXUAL. IS IN THE WORKPLACE IS
BROUGHT TO HUMAN RESOURCE BY A
MINOR THE COMPLAINT WILL BE
MADE TO A- MAY. ORDER SEC GAP
MADAM CHAIR I BILL THERE ARE
WITNESS JOINING A TODAVíA
TELEPHONE RON RAP FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND DENNIS SEATON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHURCH STATE
COUNCIL THANK YOU YES WILL TURN
TO THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS RON
RAP GO AHEAD. OPERATOR ON RAP
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS VON RAAB
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE PURSUE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THE NUMBER SERVICE NEWS
FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD TO HIGHER
EDUCATION ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES THIS PROTECTING OUR
STUDENTS. ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE CONSIDERED MANDATED
REPORTERS AND THEY TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY
WE SUPPORT AB NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE BY
ADDING TO THE LIST OF MANDATED
REPORTERS HUMAN RESOURCE
PROFESSIONALS THE BUSINESSES
THAT EMPLOY MINORS AND DIRECT
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISORS OF
MINORS WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED
THE WORKPLACE AS WELL WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK. THANK YOU STRAP IS
DENNIS ON THE LINE. DO WE HAVE
DENNIS SEATON WHO IS THE OTHER
LEAD WITNESS. WE DON'T OKAY
THEN I'M GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINE OPERATOR FOR ANYONE ELSE
HE'S CALLING IN SUPPORT
PERHAPS- DENNIS SEATON WILL
JOIN AFTER. A GO AHEAD OPERATOR
IN SUPPORT AB NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE. WE GET DENNIS- PRO
SETON THE IS ON THE LINE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TENNESSEE
TEN. AND YOU REPRESENTED A
TRICIA COUNCIL. ORGANISED OF
THE SEVEN SEVEN CHURCH. I'M
WILLING TO OF THE BILL AND FROM.
MY EX WAS WILL WORK WITH THE
TAKE CHARGE FROM NINETY NINETY
TO TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE IN
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF SEVENTH DAY
ADVENTISTS. STATION CHOSE HAVE
COME FISH OR DIRECTOR WHICH WAS
WHAT I WAS HAND OTHER PASSERS
AND OTHER PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE ADDED TO
REPORTERS I FOUND THAT IT WAS
VERY AND FOR ME PERSONALLY AS
AN HR PERSON TO BE REMINDED
THAT THERE ARE VULNERABLE
CHILDREN THAT ARE WORKING MINOR
CHILDREN THERE WERE TWO IN THE
WORKPLACE AND THAT WHAT MIGHT
NOT. COME BUT A RIGHT WILL
WINTER RYE TO. SUCH HARASSMENT.
BUT IT ALSO COULD BE CHILD
ABUSE AND THAT WE NEEDED TO
REPORT THAT. CONSOLE BECAUSE OF
THAT EXPERIENCE AND- THAT HOLD
THAT HELPED ME BE- COGNIZANT OF.
WATCHING FOR ABUSE IN THE
WORKPLACE. WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THREE HAVE A ANY OF A-
WITNESSES ON THE LONG. OPERATOR.
EIGHT I DO NOT BELIEVE SO NOW.
I HAVE NO ONE IN THE I HAVE NO
ONE IN THE PHONE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME OKAY LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE AND PHYSICALLY IN THE
ROOM FOR A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE OTHER ROOM.
SEEING NINE SO WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED SO LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANY CALLING IN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. AND IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD AGAIN THAT IS A ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
I HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP ON THE
PHONE. RIGHT NO OPPOSITION DOWN
FOR AB NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
MEMBERS WORDS OR ANY COMMENTS
YOU'D LIKE TO MATCH OUR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE IS THERE
A MOTION FOR THE BILL. OFFER
GREAT CENTER MORE LARK IS MOVED
IT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
A FRO AGAIN ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SENATOR WILL JACKSON YOU MAY
CLOSE NO I CHANGE THE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR HI VOTE ON A
BILL THAT WILL PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF CHILDREN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND GIVE NEEDED
GUIDANCE TO THOSE EMPLOYERS.
WHO HIRE CHILDREN AND THE
EMPLOYEES WHO SUPERVISED WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE
RIFLE. EXCELLENT SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR MORE LARK. IT
IS TO PASS TWO PROBES. BUT WE
WILL DO A ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE DID PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER ART. IN
OUR AYE MORLOCK. BY MOORLACH
AYE BRADFORD. JACKSON HI
JACKSON I MITCHELL. THE LIVE
METROLINE MORALE. SENATOR
MORALE HI MORALE AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE BRADFORD ARE BRED
FOR AG VOTERS OUT OF BILL IS AT
SEVEN ZERO. FOUR EIGHT AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO. AND THANK YOU MADAM
TRIP YOU'RE WELCOME SENATOR
JACKSON WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
THIRTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS AND US
SENATOR BRADFORD IS PRESENTING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN RISON
PRESENTING TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN. AND THE AUTHOR
HAS ASKED ME TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE FROM THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THE HELP THEY HAVE-
PROVIDED IN GETTING THIS
MEASURE TO WORD IS TODAY I WILL
BE ACCEPTING. THE RECOMMENDED-
AMENDMENTS FOR FROM THE
ANALYSIS. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN THE STREET FOR MEASURE
THAT ALLOWS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATED
AT ONE OF THE CD OURS
CONSERVATION FAR CAMPS TO APPLY
FOR EXPUNGEMENT. THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE VETTED BY THIS
DR STRICT CRITERION DURING OUR
FIRE SEASON. PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES THEY ARE THEY ALL
EARNED THEIR RIGHT TO WORK BY
EXHIBITING NON VIOLENT BEHAVIOR
AND CONFORMING TO ALL RULES IN
ADDITION ONLY THOSE WITH
MINIMUM CUSTODY. STATUS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOLUNTEER SOME
CONVICTION OFFENSES SUCH AS
SEXUAL OFFENSES FENCES. ARSON
AND ANY HISTORY OF ESCAPE WHAT
FORCE OR VIOLENCE AUTOMATICALLY
MAKE AN INDIVIDUAL INELIGIBLE
FOR CONSERVATION CAMPUS SIMONS
EVEN IF THE INDIVIDUAL'S
MINIMAL CUTS THE STATUS. THE
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS OR ON
THE PATH THE REHABILITATION BUT
THEY CANNOT. REACH TRUE
REHABILITATION WITHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT ONE THREE LIST. IF
WE REALLY WANT TO BRING ABOUT
CHANGE AND WAR ARE RECIDIVISM
RATES WE HAVE TO MAKE CHANGES
TO THE SYSTEMATIC POLICY
SUPPRESSING OUR COMMUNITIES. AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES
JUST THAT IT WOULD ADD MUCH
NEEDED BALANCE TO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM EL ALL THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ARE
COMFORTABLE. I'M NOT FOR THE
CALL ON TO HELP FIGHT FIRES TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK AN
EXPUNGEMENT. IT IS A GRAVE
INJUSTICE TO OUR LEGAL SYSTEM
THAT WE- DEEM INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FIT TO FIGHT FIRES
FOR LITTLE OR NO PAY WHILE THEY
AREN'T THE ONLINE ON OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT WHEN THEY'RE
RELEASED THEY MUST FACED
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES BEFORE
THEY CAN EVEN EARN ALMOST
LIVING. FOR DOING THE SAME WORK.
ONLINE WE HAVE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IS KATIE TEN TOLL.
CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF LAW AND
DIRECTOR OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CLINIC AT UC IRVINE LAW SCHOOL.
WE ALSO HAVE A CLARION VOICE TO
WHAT SECOND CHANCES REALLY LOOK
LIKE IN THE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY. THAT BEING A CIVIL
NOON US WOULD COPE FIFTY CUT
FIFTY ON BEHALF AND ANTONIO
WELLINGTON. ALL WILD LAND
FIREFIGHTER FROM EL DORADO
COUNTY. AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO MOVE FORWARD TO PRACTICE.
REBEL TO IN THE PRACTICE OF
REAL BILL TATIAN WE MUST GIVE
INDIVIDUALS A TO Z. NEED TO
SUCCEED IN SOCIETY. AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN IS INSTILLING
HOPE INTO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM GIVING INDIVIDUALS
OPPORTUNITY. PROBABLY
REINTEGRATE INTO SOCIETY. ON
THAT NOTE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD WILL GO TO THE
FIRST WITNESS AND- I BELIEVE
THOSE ANTONIO WELLINGTON. GO
AHEAD ANTONIO. THANK YOUR HONOR
THIS IS KATIE TEND TO I BELIEVE
I'M THE FIRST WITNESS OKAY GO
AHEAD KATIE GO AHEAD. THANKS
THE MORNING KEREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KATIE TENTO AND I'M A
CO PROFESSOR OF LAW DIRECTOR OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE CLINIC AT
UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW.
THROUGH THE CLINIC I REPRESENT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SEEKING TO
EXPUNGE THEIR CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS. I AM VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE BARRIERS AND HURDLES
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FACE WHEN SEEKING
TO MOVE ON FROM PAST MISTAKES.
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES IN PROVIDING
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL THE PATHWAY TO
EXPUNGE THEIR CONVICTIONS.
HOWEVER INDIVIDUALS WEE
CONVICTED OF FELONIES STILL
FACE AN ENORMOUS BARRIERS IN
GETTING THIS RELIEF AND OFTEN
HAVE DIFFICULTIES FINDING
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO KNOW THAT EVEN
ONCE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY FOR AN EXPUNGEMENT OR
CERTIFICATE OF REHABILITATION
YEARS LATER. IT IS CERTAIN BY
ANY OF THE COURT WILL GRANT IT
CRIMINAL COURTS ARE HIGHLY
LOCALIZED THE DECISION IS IN
THE HANDS OF AN INDIVIDUAL
JUDGE AND THE OPINION OF THE
INDIVIDUAL PROSECUTOR IS OFTEN.
INFLUENTIAL REQUEST FOR
EXPUNGEMENT ARE OFTEN DENIED.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW AN
INDIVIDUAL TO WHO SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED ONE OF THE CCC FIRE
CAN'T PROGRAMS AS AN
INCARCERATED FIREFIGHTER. TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR AN
EXPUNGEMENT UPON HIS OR HER
RELEASE FROM CUSTODY. IT WOULD
CREATE A PATHWAY FOR
PROFESSIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
IMMEDIATELY RATHER THAN HAVING
THIS INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL WAIT
YEARS BEFORE HERE SHE COULD TRY
TO MOVE FORWARD IN THEIR
CAREER. THIS TIENEN IS CRITICAL
IT IS UPON A PERSON'S RELEASED
FROM CUSTODY WHEN THEY MOST
NEED A PATHWAY TO EMPLOYMENT.
BY ALLOWING A PERSON WHO'S
DEMONSTRATED IMPRESS
REHABILITATION BY SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING FIRE CAMP TO APPLY
FOR AN EXPUNGEMENT. THIS BILL
WERE WILL REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND
PROVIDE A CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL AS WELL AS
HIS OR HER FAMILY. WE'VE ALL
HEARD THE STORIES OF REMINDERS
OF WHY THERE IS A NEED TO GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY IF
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE THEIR
LIVES. MEMBERS I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE I ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE THE OTHER
LEAD WITNESS THE YOU HAVE
LIMITED TIME LEFT THE GO AHEAD.
SELECT ONE AND I'M JUST GONNA
BE REALLY QUICK I'M SPEAKING ON
THE BEHALF OF ANTONIO
WELLINGTON WHO IS A AMEND T. OF
MINE ON THE TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD WIRE. A WILD LAND
FIREFIGHTER IN ELDORADO COUNTY-
I'VE KNOWN AND TONY WELLINGTON
FOR THREE YEARS. TWENTY
ACCEPTED IN THE AIR CITY CALL
STRAW SUPPORT THIS BILL. IT'S
IN OUR WORK THAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED MANY UPON THE
INCARCERATED YOU SUCH AS
ANTONIO. WITH THEIR LIVES TO
SERVING THE COMMUNITY BOTH
WHILE INCARCERATED AND NOT.
SINCE I'VE BEEN HOME. AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN GIVES THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ATTIC
ADEQUATE PATHWAY TO PURSUE
MEETING FORM CLINIC- AND
BROUGHT IN THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THOSE WITH. DEVOTED THEIR
LIVES TO REHABILITATINGTHEM.
AND WANT TO GET BACK TO THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY ARE.
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THAT ARE IN THE ROOM.
SEEING NINE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S WITNESSES. OPERATOR WHO
WANTED TESTIFYING SOME OF THE
FOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND FIRST OF ALL
A LIE NUMBER EIGHTY LINE AT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
DOCUMENTS- FOR SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND NEXT OPEN LINE EIGHTY FOUR
NINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. PERSONALLY ON BEHALF
OF CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND NEXT TO OPEN LINE
SIXTY THREE LINES SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAIRMAN
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. LINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. AB JOBS WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. BACK
FROM THE BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. PLAINTIFF
DETECTS YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AND ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT. ONE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NEXT OPEN
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE MOMENT MY
TWENTY NINE. FIND TWENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AGAIN
YOU TOOK YOURSELF OUT OF Q. ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. DANNECKER O'DONNELL-
HAPPENED SAID BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. ALRIGHT
WE WILL GO TO THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IT IS
STEPHANIE MATTHEWS FROM THE DA
ASSOCIATION GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ACTUALLY THIS WAS WARY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION-
WE ARE REGRETTABLY OPPOSED TO
A. B. TWO ONE FOUR SEVEN. WHILE
WE LOG THE MOTIVATION BEHIND
THIS PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE THAT
IT SIMPLY GOES TOO FAR THIS
BILL WOULD GRANT PC TWELVE OH
THREE POINT FOUR TYPE
EXPUNGEMENT AND DISMISSAL TO
PRISON SENTENCES THAT IS A
DRAMATIC DEPARTURE LONG
STANDING POLICY WHICH
HISTORICALLY LIMITED SUCH
RELIEF TO LOWER LEVEL PROBATION
OR- PAROLE SENTENCES. EVEN WHEN
AMENDMENTS TO HI MATES L. OPEN
PROGRAM IT'S STILL APPLIES TO
PERSONS CONVICTED OF MOST
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OR THESE
SUCH AS ATTEMPTED MURDER
ROBBERY AND FIREARMS OFFENSES.
THE BILL STILL ALLOWS FOR
INSTEAD EXPUNGED AND DISMISSAL
UPON RELEASE FROM PRISON WITH
NO SUPERVISION PERIOD
WHATSOEVER NO CALL NO P. R. C.
HAS NOTHING. THAT'S A HUGE
GAMBLE THE AMENDED BILL SO THE
DENIAL OF RELIEF IS WITHOUT
PREJUDICE THAT MEANS THE
DEFENDANT CONSERVE. RECORD.
ALSO PAPER. WELL OF SCENARIO IS
POTS IT'S NOT LIKE TERMS OF THE
BILL A PERSON CONVICTED OF
CHILD BE EXCERPTED CHRIS. MADE
BY OF THE OF THIS BILL WORK IN
A DAYCARE FACILITY. OR SOMEONE
CONVICTED OF ELDER ABUSE SO
ELDER FINANCIAL CRIMES AND SENT
TO PRISON WILL UPON RELEASE THE
WORKING IN IS IN AN ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY. FOSTER IS NOT
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL WHICH WILL LEAVE A PERSON
CONVICTED OF THESE CRIMES AND
MANY OTHER SERIOUS FELONIES.
FROM DISCLOSING THAT CONVICTION
ON AN APPLICATION FOR A STATE
OR LOCAL WHITES. INCLUDING SUCH
BUSINESSES AS DAYCARE
FACILITIES AND ASSISTED LIVING
CENTERS SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN
HIDE THEIR CONVICTIONS EVEN
FROM THOSE WHO OPERATE
SENSITIVE USINESSES WITH
VULNERABLE CLIENTELE. THERE ARE
OTHER EXPUNGEMENT STATUTES ON
THE BOOKS BUT STILL REQUIRE THE
PERSON MUST DISCLOSE THE
CONVICTION FOR LICENSING
PURPOSES. THAT WILL NOT APPLY
HOWEVER TO THOSE WHO WILL
BENEFIT FROM AB TWO ONE FOUR
SEVEN. CD SHARES A BELIEF WITH
MANY OF THE COMMITTEE THE THERE
ARE TOO MANY LICENSING
RESTRICTIONS ON PERSONS
CONVICTED OF FELONIES TO
PREVENT THEM FROM EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES. WE
HAVE REPEATEDLY SIGNAL OUR
WILLINGNESS TO BEGIN A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW AND
ELIMINATE RESTRICTIONS THAT
DON'T MAKE SENSE AND QUIRK OUR
EFFORTS TO FULLY REINTEGRATE
THOSE CONVICTED OF FELONIES
BACK INTO OUR MAIN STREET. BUT
SOME OF THESE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS THE TWO
LISTED ABOVE MAKE ABUNDANT GOOD
SENSE. SURE BUSINESS OWNER HAVE
THE RIGHT TO KNOW THE PERSON
HERE SHE IS CONSIDERING HIRING
AS A HOME HEALTH CARE WORKER
WAS CONVICTED AND SENT TO
PRISON. FOR ABUSING OR STEALING.
L. BACK. STILL SAYS NO. AND
MISTER. DISAGREE WE RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR FIRE FIGHTING
PERSONNEL TO COMBAT
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE DATE. AND
WE APPRECIATE THE COURAGE AND
DEDICATION OF MANY OF THOSE
INMATES TO PERFORM THIS
DANGEROUS MORE. THERE ARE
ALREADY NUMEROUS BENEFITS THAT
ACCRUE TO AN INMATE WHO WORKS
ON FIRE YEAH LIKE TO PULL ONE
CUSTODY QUOTE. BUT THIS BILL
PLAYS FAST AND LOOSE WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE RIGHT THE
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THE
COMMUNITY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND THEIR CLIENTS WELL THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU ON THERE'S
NO OTHER LEAD WITNESS LISTED SO
WE WILL NOW TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES AND WHO ARE CALLED IN
IN OUR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ISSUE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. I HAVE
NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE. RIGHT. TO KNOW
OTHER OPPOSITION LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY CAR OR QUESTIONS.
SENATOR A. YOU KNOW I CAN THE I
HAVE FOLLOWED THIS ISSUE FOR
WAR WE HAD A CAMP FOR. A PEOPLE
WHO WERE INTERESTED PRISONERS
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN BECOMING
FIREFIGHTERS AFTER THEIR TERMS
HAD ENDED IN HAD BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN ASSISTING IN
FIGHTING FIRES MANY OF WHICH
WE'VE I'VE SADLY HEAD OF MY
DISTRICT. THE PROGRAM IS QUITE
A STRICT. AND YOU CAN'T GET
INTO THIS PROGRAM IF YOU HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF WHAT I WOULD
CALL HEINOUS CRIMES. THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
I BELIEVE ON THE PHONE CLAIMED-
THAT THAT WAS NOT THE CASE- I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS ACCURATE
OR CERTAINLY PEOPLE DON'T WANT.
PEOPLE IN THE A SENIOR
FACILITIES WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED PREVIOUSLY OF CRIMES
ASSOCIATED WITH SENIOR ABUSE
AND I'M WONDERING IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO THOSE CLAIMS THAT
WERE MADE BY THE- DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION AS TO
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE. IN THIS
PROGRAM AND WHETHER THE PROGRAM
WOULD EXTEND TO SUCH THINGS OR
WHETHER THERE'S A LITTLE
HYPERBOLE GOING ON HERE OR NOT.
I AM ALWAYS SADDENED BY. THE
STATEMENTS IN OPPOSITION BY DH
THROUGHOUT- THE STATE WHEN IT
COMES TO SECOND CHANCES IN
REHABILITATION- IT CLEARLY
STATES THE FOLKS TO COMMITTED
SEXUAL OFFENSES ARTS IN AN
INDUSTRY OF ESCAPING VIOLENCE
ARE AUTOMATICALLY- INELIGIBLE
FOR. NOT ONLY PARTICIPATE IN A
FIRE CAT BUT ALSO. THEY
WOULDN'T LEAD IN B. AND
PRESERVE FOR EXPUNGEMENT I DID
EXPUNGEMENT BILL COUPLE YEARS
AGO WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND- IT CLICKED AND IT PASSED
IN IT BUT IT CLEARLY STATES
THAT. NOTHING IS HIDDEN EVEN
WITH EXPUNGEMENT WITH THE
INTERNET AND TECHNOLOGY TODAY
YOU CAN'T HIDE FROM YOUR PAST
SO THE SIT HERE AND SAY THAT
IT'S- ARE THE EXPLAINED TO WILL
PREVENT SOMEONE FROM DOING A
BACKGROUND CHECK EVEN NEED NEED
NOT EVEN CHECKING THE BOX
PEOPLE STILL FIND OUT THAT
YOU'VE BEEN CONVICTED IT'S
SELECT. ALL WE'RE SEEING THIS
GIVE HE'S INDIVIDUAL ICE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO WHAT THEY'RE-
WHILE IN CAR. THEY HAVE PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
FIGHT FIRES ALL THROUGH DISH
WE'VE SEEN THE DEVASTATION. OF
IT'S PAST YEARS THE MOST OF THE
FOLKS FRONTLINE. ARE A MADE. I
WAS PRO DIRECTOR FOR YEARS IT
ELLIE CONSERVE CORPS MANY OF
THOSE YOUNG FOLKS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR WORKED IN BACK
COUNTRY MANY MORE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED MINIMAL FOUGHT ON
THE FIRE LINES AND THEY CAN
COME BACK. TO THEIR OLD HOME
INTO THE CITY OF LA AND GET A
JOB AT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT. AND
THEY WERE SOME OF THE BEST MOST
RELIABLE CORPS MEMBERS WE HEAD
THOSE WHO WERE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED BECAUSE THEY
APPRECIATE A SECOND CHANCE MORE
THAN MANY PEOPLE WHO. HAVE WHAT
A SILVER SPOON IN A LIVE A LIFE
IN AND OUT LIVE THE LIFE OF
PRIVILEGE SO. I THINK THE DA
OVERSTATED BILLS- EXAMPLES
AGAIN- YOU'RE ABLE TO STEAL MY-
LOOK AT ONCE BACKGROUND BUT
AGAIN IT CLEARLY STATES THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE AN
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM. IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS GO AHEAD SENATOR
MITCHELL. TAKE YOUR MUCH LET ME
STATE THAT I WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL I WAS JUST
CURIOUS AND THE- FOR JACKIE MAY
NOT KNOW BUT JUST FOR THE
RECORD WHY NOT OTHER SIMILAR
PROGRAMS INVOLVING- THE SIMILAR
PROFILE INDIVIDUALS WHY YOU
KNOW JUST A FIRE CAMP. SO THIS
AT SOME POINT OF THE AFRICAN
GET BACK TO ME BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO ME COULD BE EXPANDED BEYOND
THAT BUT I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY AND I'LL MAKE THE
MOTION TO TOP. OF THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD BE DO
PASSED TWO PROBES. PARDON ME AS
AMENDED AMENDED YEAH EXCUSE ME
IT'S TRUE THE TWO COMMITTEE
MEN'S GREAT. SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS LET'S DO
A ROLL CALL AND I HIGHLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL GO
AHEAD AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI IN
OUR AYE MORLOCK. MORE LIKE NOT
VOTING BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL ARE A
MORALE. IN ORDER MORRELL NO
SENATOR MARRANO WIENER ALL
RIGHT WIENER AYE. DESPITE THE
BILL AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
PASSES IT'S FIVE ONE THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD. OUR NEXT BILL
WHICH I HAD PREVIOUSLY-
FORGOTTEN SIXTEEN IS ON CONSENT
SO WE WILL NOT HEAR THAT WE'RE
GOING INSTEAD TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN GUESS WHAT'S IN YOUR
BRADFORD TO GET TO GET UP AGAIN.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN IS A. B.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX AND THIS
IS ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER A BILL.
BRADFORD YOU GO AHEAD THANK YOU
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
SOMEBODY OUT I'M PRESENTING
THAT'LL BE OUT FOR SOME WOMEN
RATE AS WHICH IS A TECHNICAL
BILL CLARIFIES CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT POLICY FOR
CERTIFICATION OF FOR YOU VISA
AND A T. VISA FORMS ARE YOU VIS
OUR TV'S OF FORMS GRANTED TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME TO HAVE FULLY
COOPERATED WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MANY IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRATION PETITIONERS HAVE
EXPRESSED A NEED TO FURTHER
CLARIFY STATE STATUTE IN ORDER
TO CREATE A UNIFORM STATE
POLICY THE FURTHER PROTECT
VICTIMS AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX SPEAKS TO JURISDICTION
ISSUES IF A CRIME IS COMMITTED
ON THE GROUNDS OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT HAS A SCHOOL
POLICE DEPARTMENT. BEEN THAT
AGENCY HAS YOUR TO JURISDICTION
OVER THE INCIDENT SOME OF THESE
CRIMES COULD. CHECK OUT SOME OF
THESE CRIMES ARE STALKING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
KIDNAPPING THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THE ROLES OF POLICE DEPARTMENTS
GOVERNED BY LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND THAT ACRE
CERTIFIED AGENCY MUST COMPLETE
A FORM OF A VICTIM MEET ALL
ELIGIBILITY. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ POLICY
ADVOCATE. FOR OUR CHIRLA CHURA
CHIRLA. AND I RESPECTFULLY FOR
A I'VE- THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
THE LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CONSERVE RESPONSES WITH
CHIRLA OF THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS YOUR
CALIFORNIA GREATEST IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING OUR FAMILIES
STUDENTS AND WORKERS PROVIDING
LEGAL SERVICES AND SEVEN
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA ALSO
MY NEIGHBOR ATTORNEYS OF LAW.
TO THOSE PROBLEMS BONDS AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX WHICH
WILL PROVIDE FURTHER
CLARIFICATION COME ON FORCE
MADE UC'S AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY. THAT THEY HAVE
TO FOR OUR DOUBLE AND I CAN AND
ARE HELPFUL IN THE QUESTION
CERTIFICATION OF YOUR TV SIR
FROM THE OUTSIDE AGENCY OR
OFFICER STICKS OVER THE
SPECIFIC CASE. STUDY THAT HAVE
BEEN PUBLISHED ON THE TOPIC
INDICATE THAT AGENCIES ARE ON
AWARE OF THE ROLE OF THE
CERTIFICATION PROPER ARE LIKE
GENERAL KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
YOUR TV SO WALL OTHER AGENCIES
DON'T FEEL THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE A WRONG IMMIGRATION
PROCESS. OF ALL CAN RESULT IN
THE AGENCIES OF NINE AND
DIVORCE DOCUMENT VECTOR. ARMS
CALL FOR TO PURSUE THE OWNER
PROCESS THAT'S BEEN A- BY
FEDERAL LAW. TO DATE IN THE
AREA THE PHOTO ID WHICH IS. FOR
A APPROVING AND YOUR- ARE. TO
APPROVE ABA THAT BEEN. YEARS UP
VICTIMS COOPER. WITH LONG AND
IT WAS A GOOD. THE CASE FEDERAL
STATUTE EXPLICITLY STATE THAT
THERE IS NO STATUTE LIMITATION
FOR. VICTIMS OF A CRIME- APPLY
FOR YOUR TV SO ALONG THE STATE
CERTIFICATION AT ANY TIME. AB
BOOK TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
BECAUSE OF EXISTING YOU PAUL.
EMPLOYMENTS LEGISLATURE'S
ORIGINAL ACTS AND THEN IT
TURNED OUT SB SIX SEVEN FOUR BY
SENATOR DE LEON. AND STRAIGHTEN
THE STATE'S UNIFORM POLICY TO
ELIMINATE CONFUSION AMONGST
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY AND
CLOSING. VICTIMS ARE NOT HAVE A
CHOICE WERE CRYING. I'VE BEEN
COMMITTED AGAINST FROM OUR
WHICH AGENCY HAS RESTRICTION OF
THE CASE MISSION BE PUNISHED
FOR. THIS FOR THESE REASONS FOR
THIS PRODUCT SUPPORT AND BE A
SPONSOR AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX AND WE ARE DR- NOT. BE
AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. FOR IS
THE ANY OTHER THERE'S NO OTHER
LEADS TO. IN THIS ROOM BY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX THAT WANTED TO
TESTIFY. EIGHTEEN KNOWN ABOUT
THE OTHER REMOTE ROOM. NOPE SO
LET'S OPERATOR IN SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
FIRST OPEN THE LINE OF A LINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND TO
LOSE OUT ON BEHALF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ONE TO ONE NUMBER FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING LESLIE HOUSTON ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THE NEXT OPEN LINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MICHELLE DEAL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. DâN BIãU TERRACE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. AND MY TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SANTORUM
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AT THE
TIME I HAVE NO ONE ELSE I
SHOWING FOR THE SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT THEN LET'S TURN TO OUR
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I BELIEVE
IT'S COREY CELLS HELLO FROM THE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHORUS SOLO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- CLEARLY
VICTIM COOPERATION CAN BE
EXTREMELY VALUABLE WHEN
INVESTING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATING CRIMINAL
OFFENSES. THAT SAID EXISTING ON
THIS MATTER REQUIRES SPECIFIED
OFFICIALS TO SIGN THESE
REQUESTS AND CONTAIN THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
EFFECTIVELY STATES THAT A
VICTIM IS BEING COOPERATIVE OR
IS LIKELY TO BE COOPERATIVE.
UNLESS AND UNTIL HE OR SHE IS
NOT COOPERATIVE. IF THE CASE IS
CLOSED OR THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS HAS RUN THE NEED
FOR AN OFFICIAL TO MAKE A
CERTIFICATION ABOUT VICTIM
COOPERATION SEEM TO BE MOVED.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON CSSA AS
RESPECT THE OPPOSED AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY OTHER LEAD OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK SO WILL INSTEAD GO TO THE-
THERE'S NO MORE NEWS CHANGED IN
THE ROOM AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY'S GOING INTO THE OTHER
ROOM SO I'M GONNA GO SRAIGHT
TO THE PHONE LINES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY SIX.
CERTAINLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT ARM LET'S THEN SEE THIS
IS AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY LET'S
SEE IF ANY BY MEMBERS. ALRIGHT
THEN I'LL LET- SENATOR BRADFORD
CLOSE AND WE'LL SEE IF THERE IS
A MOTION. IRISH REQUEST FOR A
VOTE. ALRIGHT A MOTION SIR
MOTION. OKAY SENATOR JACKSON
HAS MOVED THE BILL AND THAT IS-
DO PASSED TO THE FLOOR AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX LET'S DO
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX MOTIONS DO PASS
SKINNER BY IN OUR ONLINE MORE
LOCKED. NOT VOTING- BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON ACTION AYE
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL. MITCHELL
AYE MORALE. SENATOR MORALE I
KNOW FEDERAL NARROW WIENER. BUT
THE LONG CALL FOR SENATOR
WINNER ALL RIGHT TO VOTE SO FAR
AS FOUR TO ONE BUT WE WILL PUT
IT ON HOLD AND WE WILL MOVE TO
OUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE. SENATOR STONE AND
CENTER BRADFORD YOU ARE
PRESENTING. CAN I AM GOING TO
GIVE THE- GAVEL TEMPORARILY TO
MY VICE CHAIR. AND I WILL
RETURN OF OUR KERRY QUICKLY
OKAY. I'D GO AHEAD CENTER
RADFORD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE ON BEHALF OF
SOMEONE STONE THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT ANY INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ON DEATH ROW ARE RE
SENTENCED AND WILL PROTECT
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED PEOPLE
FROM BEING SENTENCED TO DEATH
IN THE FUTURE. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THE SUPREME COURT
DETERMINED THAT THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION PROHIBITS THE
EXECUTION OF INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED PEOPLE. CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE ENACTED A LAW
TO CODIFY THAT DECISION THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. OVER THE NEXT
SEVENTEEN YEARS THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY MADE FAST ADVANCE
VANCE'S. AND OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND
DISABILITIES BUT THE LARGEST
HAS NOT MODERNIZE THE LAW TO
REFLECT THOSE ADVANCES. AS A
RESULT CALIFORNIA USES UNFAIR
AND OUTDATED STANDARDS TO
DETERMINE IF SOMEONE IS
INELIGIBLE FOR EXECUTION. IT IS
LIKELY THAT SOME OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY INDIVIDUALS
CURRENTLY WAITING ON DEATH ROW
HAVE INTELLECTUALLY.
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
ACCORDING TO CLINICAL STANDARDS
THOSE INDIVIDUALS MUST BE RE
SENTENCED AND REMOVED FROM
DEATH ROW. AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE WILL UPDATE THE PENAL
CODE AND REFLECT THE PROGRESS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE BY
REQUIRING ON SET OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES TO
HAVE OCCURRED DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT PERIOD. CLARIFYING
THAT IN POST CONVICTION
PROCEEDINGS. EXPERTS ON
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES MUST
TESTIFY TO OUT OF COURT
STATEMENTS USED AND INFORMING
THEIR OPINION AND ALLOWING A
PERSON TO MAKE A SHOWING OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY BY
USING THE KIND OF EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD BE RELIED UPON BY A
QUALIFIED EXPERT. ADDITIONALLY
AB. TWELVE TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
WILL PROHIBIT PROSECUTORS FROM
ARE GOING TO POP UP. A PERSON'S
IQ. BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE TO
RENDER THEM ALL DOUBLE FOR
EXECUTION. A. B. LIKE TAKING A
COGNITIVE BRING TO US IN BEING
ABLE TO IDENTIFY ITEMS IN BE
NOW CLASSIFIED AS A STABLE
GENIUS. THIS IS A BLATANT
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AND WE
CANNOT ALLOW IT TO CONTINUE IN
A CALIFORNIA COURT ROOMS. WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT THE DEATH
PENALTY KILLS INNOCENT PEOPLE
AND IS APPLIED UNEQUAL ALONG
RACIAL AND SOCIO ECONOMICAL.
ECONOMIC LINES WE ALSO KNOW
THAT INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
PEOPLE FACE A HIGHER RISK ARE
WRONGFUL EXECUTION. IN PASSING
B TWELVE TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
OUR STATE WILL ADOPT THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY'S DEFINITION
OF INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY AND
WILL PROHIBIT ARTIFICIAL
INFLATION OF AYE CUES TO MAKE
BLACK AND LEAD KNACKS PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE FOR EXECUTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD WE
NOW HAVE TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES OF ONE WE HAVE ON THE
LINE- NEW SHOULD SHOW AND WE'RE
WAITING FOR A TASHA. MINSKER SO
LET'S START WITH MICHELLE. GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS NATION'S
JOHN I'M ACTUALLY THE ONLY
SUBSTANTIVE WITNESS IN SUPPORT-
I'M LEGAL DIRECTOR AT THE
HABEAS CORPUS RESOURCE CENTER
AND MISTER STONE STAFF ASKED ME
TO ADDRESS HOW AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE. WILL BRING CALIFORNIA'S
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY STATUTE
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH U. S.
SUPREME COURT LAW. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE OUR LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THREE ADDING SECTION
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX OF THE
PENAL CODE AND CODIFYING AT
CONVENE VIRGINIA. DIDN'T SEND
THE US SUPREME COURT HAS ISSUED
SEVERAL OPINION OF CLARIFYING
AND EXPANDING UPON THEIR HOLDEN
ATKINS STRAPPING OVER AND OVER
THAT STATES MUST. OKAY TO THE
SIGN INTO ABILITY PEEL CODE
SECTION THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
AND CONTRAST HAS BEEN UPDATED
ONLY WANT TO CHANGE THE TERM
MENTALLY RETARDED TO
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BRINGS THE
STATUTE IN LINE WITH THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT OF FORTY AND
CURRENT CLINICAL STANDARDS.
EVERY AMENDMENT PROPOSED HERE
IS ALIGNED WITH THE AMERICAN
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION YES
SOME FIVE IN THE PUBLICATIONS
OF THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION ON
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. FIRST AS A
SCIENTIFIC MATTER THE
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD EXTENDS
BEYOND THE EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THE
DSM FIVE DROPPED A STRICT AGE
CUT OFF FOR INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY DEFINING IT AS A
CONDITION THAT MUST MANIFEST.
DURING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
PERIOD. THIS BILL DOES THE SAME.
SECOND CLINICAL STANDARDS
REQUIRE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO RELY ON A
THOROUGH SOCIAL HISTORY
RELEVANT RECORDS AND DOCUMENTS
AND FORMAL INTERVIEWS IN
ASSESSING INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY. AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE BRINGS CALIFORNIA LAW
INTO ACCORD WITH U. S. SUPREME
COURT PRECEDENT BY ALLOWING
JUDGES TO HEAR AND CONSIDER ALL
CLINICALLY RELEVANT EVIDENCE.
THIRD BY CREATING AN ALTERNATE
WAY TO MAKE A PRIMA FASHION
SHOWING THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA COURTS BETTER
IDENTIFY THOSE FACING EXECUTION
WHO MAY BE INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED. THERE IS NO
DISADVANTAGE TO THE STATE HERE
THE DEFENDANT OR PETITIONER
STILL HAS THE BURDEN OF PROOF
AT A HEARING AND THE FACT
FINDERS FINAL DECISION WILL
ALWAYS BE BASED ON THE EVIDENCE
THE PARTY TO PREVENT. FINALLY
TO WORK IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS TO KNOW THAT RACISM
IN FACT IT. WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
SINCE ATKINS IS THAT RACISM
PLAGUE THOSE HEARINGS AS WELL.
BEER IS IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVE ARGUED IN ESSENCE THAT
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE THEIR I. Q. SCORES
ADJUSTED UPWARD. BECAUSE THE
TESTS WERE MADE FOR THEM. BUT
HAVE NO GROUNDING IN AND IS
CONTRARY TO THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY STANDARDS FOR
EVALUATING INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY. ARTIFICIALLY
INFLATING A PERSON OF COLOR IQ
SO THAT WE CAN EXECUTE THEM IS
ANTITHETICAL TO THE STATE'S
IDEALS AND TO THE CONSTITUTION.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE WHEN THAT
THE STATE IDENTIFIES AND
PREVENTS THE EXECUTION OF
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED PEOPLE
ADDS THE CONSTITUTIONAL CHOIRS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MICHELLE.
WE ALSO. I NOW WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN THE ROOM.
MACHINE NINE- ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE THEN WILL TURN IT
OVER TO THE MODERATOR AND TAKE
CUT CALLS FROM THOSE IN SUPPORT
ONLINE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE
UP IN SUPPORT YOU MY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD AGAIN THAT IS ONE DâN ZERO
WILL GO TO LINE EAT THESE LINE
EACH ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MR JOHNSON PORT ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATION. THE MEMBER
PROJECT. ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE. CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. GOT CAUGHT
THE ALLIANCE. DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA. EAGLE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHT. EQUAL
JUSTICE USA. EQUAL JUSTICE
SOCIETY. FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION INITIATE JUSTICE.
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. NEXT GEN
QUALITY RESTORED TO THE- IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS MINSTER A LINE NUMBER.
THANK YOU L<c.cyan>G. SIXTY FOUR IS</c>
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CO CHAIR
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRYING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO ELECT AND NEXT TO
NUMBER IN SIX LINE. NINE GOOD
MORNING AND WITH THE ARK AND
USE PEAK COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE THE NEXT
LINE FIFTY SIX LINE FIVE SIX.
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER
ASSOCIATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT LINE THREE EIGHT
GO AHEAD. MY GOD DR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER. NINETY
FOUR NINE NINE FOUR. THE MATTER
BURKE THOUGH THEY COUNT ONE
DONALD BILL READ STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER NINETY SEVEN LINE
NINE SEVEN. A LITTLE ON HAVE
THE CHILD SEARCHING IN JUST IN
STRONG SO I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
LOG SUPPORT FOR A B. JUNE ONE
OR SEVEN OR EIGHT IF YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET IN TO DO
THAT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWENTY THAT IS LINE TWO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BEING A GOOD
CARE IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
AND IF ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO
GET INTO THE PHONE QUEUE YOU
WILL PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE PHONE
TWO PLEASE CONTINUE. SORRY WE
WILL TURN TO OUR- LEAD. WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION. AND A I BELIEVE
IT'S FROM THE DA'S ASSOCIATION
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING. THIS IS
ANGELA BACKERS CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. GOOD MORNING RANDALL
ATTACKERS I AM JUST RECENTLY
RETIRED- ALAMEDA COUNTY
PROSECUTOR HANDLING CAPITAL
CASES FOR TWENTY YEARS
PROSECUTOR FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS
AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CAPITALIZATION COMMITTEE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- THIS
BILL IS. FLAWED IN MANY WAYS
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS I'LL
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
STERN YOURS OPPOSITION TO IT
BECAUSE IT STRIPS CRIME VICTIMS
AND THEIR LOVED ONE. OF ALL OF
THEIR RIGHTS WITH REGARD TO
MURDER CASES AND OUT OF THIS-
THIS LAW THE LOT OF FOLKS WHO
ARE INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED IS
GUARANTEED BY THE UNITED STATES
A PRE COURT TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO. UNDER THE CASE OF ATKINS
BURST OF VIRGINIA AND IT
DEFINES INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
IF WE DO NOT NEED A LOT OF. IN
ADDITION TO NOT BEING CRIME
VICTIMS. OF THEIR RIGHT TO THAT
THIS CLAIM COULD BE ADDED WERE
CRIME VICTIMS HAVE NO PRESIDENT
NO SAY NO RIGHT. AT THE LAST
MINUTE BY A HABEAS. PETITION
WHEN THE CRIME VICTIMS AREN'T
EVEN NOTIFIED AND PRESIDENT AND
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE IN THE
COURTROOM THIS COULD BE DONE-
VIA HABEAS MANY YEARS LATER. IT
ALSO CHANGES THE DEFINITION OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY TO MAKE
IT VAGUE ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS AND THAT IS BECAUSE
IT IS CLEAR THE DEFINITION OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY DOES
NOT NEED TO BE CHANGED. AGE IS
VERY CLEAR THAT ALL QUALIFIED
EXPERT PHD AND MEDICAL EXPERTS
ALL AGREE THAT A PERSON WHO
SUFFERS FROM AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY MANIFEST ITSELF WELL
BEFORE THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN.
THIS BILL IS VAGUE AND
COMPLETION. BECAUSE IT IS WELL
IT COULD DEVELOP ANYTIME BY ANY
DOCTOR COME THAT. EIGHTEEN BUT
JUST RECENTLY THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE SOME KIND OF INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AND THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT PROSECUTORS
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO WHAT WAS
STATED TO YOU A MOMENT AGO
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE. THAT
PROSECUTORS ARGUE TO CAPITAL
JURY. THAT YOU MUST TO PUMP UP
AN IQ SCORE OF A PERSON OF
COLOR SO THAT THEY CAN NOT BE
EXECUTED THAT IS A FALSE CLAIM.
AND SO I AM URGING YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE IT'S
UNNECESSARY IT'S ALREADY
GOVERNED BY THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT AND- SANDWICHES
YOUR TURN LEAD LINED THE WAY IT
IS. YOU HAVE HIT YOUR AND IT
MAKES IT BAG ARBITRARY
COMPLETION THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHTS LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR THERE'S NO
ONE WHO'S COME INTO THIS ROOM
SO I KNOW THAT THERE'S NINE TO
CLEAN THIS. WILL YOU QUEUE UP
ANY CALLERS IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
KEEP UP BY PRESSING ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO.
YOU HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. CORRECT SO- LET'S
SEE IF THERE IS- COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THE- DICE SENATOR
MITCHELL. OKAY CENTER JACKSON
YEAH ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LAST WITNESSES TESTIMONY THAT
THIS BILL EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION AND DOES MORE THAN
CONF- CONFORMANCE TO THE
FEDERAL LAW COULD YOU RESPOND
TO THAT. I DON'T BELIEVE IT
EXPANDS IT JUST SAYS IT BRINGS
IT UP THE CALIFORNIA HASN'T
DONE ANYTHING AND SEVENTEEN
YEARS SINCE THE RULING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO. THERE IS AN
IN LINE TO. OF THE CLINICAL
ADVANCES IN. THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCOVERED SINCE THAT TIME
IN AND BRINGS PENAL CODE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH WHAT WAS PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO. THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE- ED. THANK
YOU THE AT THE OTHER QUESTION
ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED ABOUT TAKING AWAY.
THE RIGHTS OF VICTIMS I'M NOT
QUITE SURE UNDERSTOOD I AND
THAT BUT THAT'S- WOULD BE OF
CONCERN DO YOU HAVE ANY
UNDERSTANDING OF WESTEROS
SPEAKS NOTHING TO THAT AND IT'S
NO REASON WHY ONE WOULD. REMOVE
A VICTIMS RIGHTS TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION OR ANYTHING ELSE TO.
ONCE EXECUTION OR- SENTENCING
SO THIS BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS
THAT AT ALL SO. THANK YOU. I
WOULD JUST THE STATE THAT THE
ANALYSIS IN RESPONSE TO THAT
THE ANALYSIS INDICATES CLEARLY
THAT. ALL THE BILL DOES IS
REVISED THE DEFINITION TO- THE-
IT CONSISTENT WITH THE ADAPTIVE
BEHAVIOR IN FIVE. CURRENT
CLINICAL STANDARDS SO THE
REVISION DOES NOT BY THE NOW
SIS- MEET THE- TYPE OF CHANGE
THAT THE OPPOSITION
REPRESENTATIVE DESCRIBED AND-
SO YOU CAN LOOK AT PAGE FOUR OF
THE ANALYSIS WORD DESCRIBES
WHAT THE BILL DOES IN TERMS OF
THE CHANGE IN DEFINITION. THANK
YOU MADAM TRUCK MIGHT HAVE
MISSED SOMETHING BAD A
DESPONDENT RECOGNIZES THE
CLINICAL STAND GO AHEAD SENATOR
DIETARY RING WITH YOU JUST MIND
AND MODERNIZES CLINICAL
STANDARDS. LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THREE THIRTEEN- NINE
SENATOR- BRADFORD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES I WANT TO
THANK JOHN. BOB 20% THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S ONE WHOSE TIME HAS
COME AGAIN- HISTORY OF SHOWN
THAT THE MAJORITY OF FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN EXECUTED IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN PEOPLE OF
COLOR- MANY TIMES IT'S PROVEN
INNOCENT AND ALSO MANY TIMES
WITH INTELLECTUAL CHALLENGES
THAT WOULD DEEM OTHER FOLKS AN
ELIGIBLE FOR THE DEATH PENALTY.
AND IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC THAT
WE ARE GOING TO POP UP- BLACK
AND BROWN FOLKS INTELLECTUAL
CATHOLIC BACK TO PASSAGE WHEN
IT COMES TO EXECUTING ON BUT
NOT IN CONSIDERATION OF COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS OR JOBS IN. IN THE
COUNTRY SO. WITH THAT WE SHOULD
LAST FOR. THANK YOU- LET'S SEE.
THIRD. YES I NOISE ABOUT I'M
JUST CHECKING TO SEE FAR MORE
PARTICIPANT HAD ANY COMMENT BUT
THE HAND IS NOT UP SO IS THERE
A MOTION ON THE BILL. CENTER
JACKSON MOVES THE BILL- ON IT
IS IT WOULD BE DO PASSED TO THE
FLOOR. THEN I WANTED TO THINK-
BEFORE I TAKE. ASK FOR THE ROLL
CALL IN WHEN IT THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE AND BY EXTENSION
HIS PRESENTER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THE DEFINITIONS THAT WE
ARE USING IN THE PROCEDURES AND
PRACTICES WE ARE USING TO FIT
THE CURRENT. CLINICAL
DEFINITIONS WE HAVE MADE
VARIOUS ADJUSTMENTS INTO OUR
STATUTES AND CODES BASED ON.
NEW MEDICAL. INFORMATION NEW
RESEARCH NEW SCIENCE ON A
VARIETY OF THINGS. AND I THINK
THIS IS. AN IMPORTANT IN JUST
MEANT CONSIDERING THAT IT IS.
THE BRING IT IS A THE STATUTE
THAT IS A DETERMINER ON WHETHER
AS WE GET SOMEONE A DEATH
SENTENCE OR NOT. SO I SUPPORT
THE BILL AND- WE WILL NOW HAVE.
BUT THE- CALL THE ROLL AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE MOTIONS TO
PASS SKINNER BY IN OUR AYE MORE
LOCK. MOORLACH NOT VOTING
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE MORALE ENTER MILE NOT
BUILDING. FEMORAL NOT VOTING
WIENER. WIENER FIVE VOTERS OUT
FIVE ZERO BY TEN PASSES AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE IS OUT FIVE
ZERO AND WE WILL NOW GO TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND SENATOR WINNER YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING.
THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR BY FAILING FIRM-
PRESENTING THIS- ITEM ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL- AND
ON BEHALF OF- SO MEMBER
GABRIEL- WE ARE A- I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL. ONE
MEN'S WHICH I. SOME HAS
ACCEPTED. AND OUT WAR MOVIES.
OPPOSITION THIS LEGISLATION
BUILDS ON THE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION WORK THAT THE CHAIR
AND OTHERS HAVE ENGAGE IN
RECENT YEARS. HELP SAVE LIVES
BY STRENGTHENING. CALIFORNIA'S
LAW REGARDING GUN VIOLENCE.
RESTRAINING ORDERS ODDS AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HONORS
AND FOR HIS LAWFUL GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS ISSUED IN
THE STATE'S AS LONG AS-
STANDARD TO OBTAIN THOSE WATERS
IS THE SAME AS IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE THESE RESTRAINING ORDERS TO
SAVE LIVES AND SURE- THAT
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE GUNS
I DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THEM
BUT THE LOOPHOLE IS THAT IF YOU
HAVE A RESTRAINING ORDER IN
ANOTHER STATE YOU CAN COME TO
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE NOT. BOUND BY.
TO THE SMALL WORLD INSIDE AND-
THAT WE CONTINUED MOVE AWAY
FROM A- FRAGMENTED AND- AS A
RESULT- NOT VERY EFFECTIVE OUR
SYSTEM- AND THAT WE ON THIS
RESTRAINING ORDER IS ISSUED AND
OTHER STATES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WILL. FOR THIS AND
THAT IS. RELATED SCRIPT PAGES
TO QUICKLY- ALEXANDER WALKER
GRIFFIN LIKE TO GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GAY
GIRL FOR GIVE ME A CHANCE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX SEVENTEEN CHIEF LOBBYIST
FOR MARK FOR A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M PROUD
BECAUSE THE OP THE. TO HELP
PREVENT GUM DOUBTS ABOUT UNITY
DALY SIXTEEN STATES HAVE
SIMILAR LAWS MANY MILES UP THE
SENATOR SKINNER IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN HOWEVER SOMEONE
PROHIBITS IN PURCHASING A
FIREARM AND OTHER STATE. THE
ABILITY TO PURCHASE ONE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WOULD DRESS BY
MAY IT ILLEGAL TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU'RE
FROM ANOTHER STATE. BY
PROVIDING A FIVE YEAR BAN ON
PURCHASING ELEVEN FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION IN VIOLATION OF THE
OUT OF STATE ORDER THIS BILL
SUPPORT THE STEPS THE STATE ARE
YOU TAKING TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE AND INCREASED HEAT. IN
THE ISSUES THAT COULD VIOLATE
STRONG SUPPORT THE LEGISLATION
AND BANG ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABLE
FOR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW THE NEXT TO- LEAD
WITNESS I BELIEVE IS TIFFANY
MATTHEWS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS REMEMBER
GABRIEL FOR THE CHANCE TO PROVE
THAT THE PART OF AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN I'M PROUD TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING STATE
BOX WHICH ALREADY RECOGNIZES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS AND OTHER FORMS
PROTECTIVE ORDERS BACK FROM
OTHER STATE. BY THE READY TO
ARE AS OF DATE AND LOCAL LAW
FORCED WILL BE A TO AND BUT
ORDER WHEN RUN OF OTHERS HIPPOS
A DAY RISK OF GUNFIRE COSTS AND
IT. AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN THE
CARD MEASURE BATTLE CREEK
ANOTHER TOOL. TO HELP PREVENT
I'M NOT. TRAGEDY OPERATING ON
FOR. TO TEMPORARY REMOVE HIGHER
I. NO IN STATES THAT BUT NOT
RIGHT. ALL LEVELS GOVERNMENT
CURRENTLY ROUGHLY WITH THE CO
MIGHT CORRECT. THE EFFORT TO
REDUCE PUBLIC AND SAFETY
EMERGENCY RUN BY MUST REMAIN A
TOP PRIORITY STRONGLY SUPPORTED
BY THE- THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU. NOW LET'S SEE IF THERE ANY
OF FIRST IN OUR ROOMS TO TELL
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX SEVENTY.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO SEE WHO'S
CALLING IN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY. IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD WE'LL GO
TO LINE ET THREE LINE EIGHT
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY OF VENTURA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. GOOD A LINE
NUMBER THIRTEEN. LINE THREE
NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IZABELLA DISS
SO ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SIX ONE SEVEN. GOOD A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND ONE LINE
ONE ZERO ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO JIM LIMBURG- BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE UP LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED TO LINE
ONE ZERO TWO. ENTER MEMBER GARY
NUMAN ON BEHALF OF TO GET THOSE
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE HOPEFULLY SUPPORT.
HAVE LINE NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
LINE FIVE FIVE. ENSURE MILITARY
RECITE SURE OF THE ASIAN FOR.
IF MY NUMBER SIXTEEN LINE ONE
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. HE'LL
COMMISSION SHALL BE ON THE
HAPPENED TRANSACTION AND BEFORE
THE BALLOT WHILE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE L<c.cyan>G NUMBER FORTY SEVEN</c>
LINE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING ISN'T ANY. HAPPENED
I'LL NEED A COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. MY NUMBER NINETY NINE
NINE NINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO THIS IS MARK
NEUBERGER WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WE'RE THE SPONSOR THIS
BILL AND HERE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT. YOU'RE TELLING WHAT.
NUMBER NINETEEN LINE ONE EIGHT
NINE GOING. HI MY NAME IS MIA
PORTER AND THE GUN VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR AND A VOLUNTEER LEADER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND I
SUPPORT AND KNOW. ONE SEVEN. Q.
IF ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO GET
INTO THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT IS ONE DâN ZERO. I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. FOUR EIGHT NINE. LET
THE. GOOD OR LEAD OPPOSITION.
STARTED WITHDRAWING BUT I GUESS
NOT I THOUGHT THE ACLU ISSUE AS
WE THE AMENDMENT SO WHAT'S YOUR
FOR ME CO YOU OF A JUST TO
CLARIFY GO AHEAD LEAD
OPPOSITION. YES MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS MIKE AT DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ON AND WE HAVE
INDEED. ARE OPPOSITION AND
LIGHT AT THE RECENT AMENDMENT-
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND.
NINETEEN NINETY. THANK YOU
LET'S TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE CALLING IN FOR OPPOSITION.
YES MADAM CHAIR NOT SURE HER
NAME IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRADE FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. WE DO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF THE AUTHOR TO. THE
BILL- WE CAN GET DOES NOT TAKE
A POSITIVE STEP. REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL HOWEVER. ACTIONS WE
ARE CREATING A NEW. NO OFFENSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE IS AS TIGHT AS
POSSIBLE TO THAT INDIVIDUALS DO
NOT. TELLS SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION BASED ON. ON AN
UNCERTAINTY IN THE LANGUAGE-
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE WOULD
BE CONTINUE TO HAVE IS THAT
THERE MAY BE INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVE IN ANOTHER STATE. CORD
THAT HE- IF THE WITH APPLICABLE
ESTATE WE TO ANOTHER AND THIS
COULD COME INTO A SECOND TYPE
OF CASE WHEN OUR- CENTER ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY TO BE MAY BE.
INDIVIDUALS AWESOME TO WE THE
STATE. TO RESTART LIVES GET A
FOR SUCH GO AWAY FROM PERSON
BUT THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
AND IS THE OF BEGIN THEIR LIVES
IN NEW THE STATE. WE HAVE HAD
QUE. THAT WOULD BE THAT WE DO
COULD BE. WHERE INDIVIDUALS
ALLOCATE START. ONE AROUND THE
PERSON ANY STILL SEVERAL AWAY
WE COULD POTENTIALLY. OUT BY.
MISDEMEANORS YOU CAN DOWN
BECAUSE THEY WERE UNAWARE I
WILL NOT NOTIFY THE BILL
APPLIES. THE SO HAPPY COULD YOU
COME. DOCTORS ARE DO APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR THAT YEAH. YOU THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT LET ASIDE HAVE
ANY LINE IN OFF OPERATOR GO
AHEAD. THE LIKE TO QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IS
LOOKING AT. AND RIGHT. LET'S IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS. GO AHEAD SENATOR JEFF I
JUST DON'T WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND ALSO
FOR- ACTUALLY INCORPORATING
LANGUAGE THAT I HAD IN THE BILL
OF. THAT HER WITHIN ASKED HIM
TO ADD TO HIS MEASURE IN ORDER
TO PULL DOWN IMPAIR DOWN THE
OUR VILLAGE THIS HERE- YOU KNOW
THESE ARE REALLY CRITICAL
THESE- RESTRAINING ORDERS XIN
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR
FOR HAVING INTRODUCED THIS
ISSUE BACK. IN FOURTEEN ARE AND
I CHECKED THIS IS. SAVED MANY
MANY LIVES- SO IT'S VERY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. I'M
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THAT THE
CONSUMER THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RESEARCH CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE ARE STILL
OPPOSED I THINK THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN. THE REQUESTED
THE A. B. YOU HAVE TIGHTENED
THE- I AM HAVING TROUBLE
IMAGINING THOSE INSTANCES
WHERE- THERE WOULD BE A SOMEONE
CAUGHT IN THE OF. KIND OF THE
MIDDLE AND NOT AWARE SO THAT
THEY WOULD FIND THEMSELVES
SUBJECT TO A CRIMINAL PENALTY I
HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT THE
CA CJ HAS EXCELLENT LEGAL
REPRESENTATION AND- THAT THESE
FOLKS WOULD BE. ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE EXCESSIVELYSHOULD IT
HAPPEN I HAVE A LITTLE TROUBLE
IMAGINING IT BUT- FOR THAT IT
WOULD HAPPEN BUT I THINK THIS
BILL IS A VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND- TIGHTENS UP SOME
OF THE RECALL TRANSACTION MORE
THAN ANYTHING TO MAKE IT MORE.
WHAT AND IN CAN'T TO THE TO THE
VIOLENCE AND THAT UP. WE TO
MAKE SURE THE DAY TO VERY AS
WELL AND I THINK THE BILL DOES
SAT SO. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU HAVE MOTION
SPEAK TO IT- SO THIS THIS WHOLE
NOTION OF WHAT IS NOW CALLED
EXTREME RISK. ORDER IN OTHER OR
RED FLAG LAWS IN OTHER STATES
WAS STARTED BY CALIFORNIA WE
WERE THE FIRST TO PUT THROUGH
WHAT WE CALL TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER AND DID SO AS
SOON JACKSON POINT IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AFTER THE REALLY AWFUL
SHOOT THAT OCCURRED IN HER. IN
HER DISTRICT WHEN. YOU SEE SOME
OF OUR RAN ON ISLA VISTA AND
THE- WHAT I WANT TO SAY IS THAT
I APPRECIATE THE ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE THE I
APPRECIATE THEIR CONSISTENCY
LOOKING VERY CAREFULLY AT EVERY
BILL THAT WE ADDRESS BECAUSE AT
FIRST. AND I THINK THAT THIS
BàN A RESPECTIVE OF THE SENATE
IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY WE ARE TRYING TO
DO OUR BEST. TO ONLY CREATE A
NEW CATEGORY OF CRIME WHEN WE
REALLY FEEL IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AND WE HAVE WE HAVE
REJECTED BILL WERE OME AUTHORS
HAVE FELT THAT A NEW CATEGORY
OF CRIME WAS REALLY NECESSARY
AND WE LOVED IT OTHERS. YEAH
BUT I THINK WE'VE REALLY. LET
IN THE RIVER I AM SO TODAY EVEN
THOUGH IT DOES DO WHAT THE
CRIMINALS ARE ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE RAISED IS THAT
I AM HAVE AS THE ORIGINAL
AUTHOR OF THIS LAW HAVE
MONITORED OTHER STATES HAVE A
DOT IN MOST OTHER STATES HAVE
PATTERNED THEIR LAWS AFTER
CALIFORNIA'S SO IN NOW ARE A
LOT HAS BEEN MODIFIED OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS. I'M AND- IT
TO INCLUDE IT BOTH. ALSO ADDED
SOME RESTRICTIONS AND MANY
STATES HAVE PATTERN THAT AND SO
I FEEL THAT. GIVEN THAT THE
VERY PURPOSE OUR LAW IS
ENHANCED OR IS IMPROVED IF
ANYONE WHO COMES FROM ANOTHER
STATE WHO IS UNDER SUCH A
RESTRAINING ORDER THAT IT
CONTINUES WITH THEM BECAUSE OUR
WHOLE PURPOSE ALREADY KNOW THAT
UNFORTUNATELY. OR OTHER GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION LAWS WERE
NO ABLE TO REALLY AFFECT STATE
TO STATE SO IN OTHER WORDS IF
YOU'RE- YOU CAN GO ACROSS STATE
LINES EVEN THOUGH TECHNICALLY
AS A CALIFORNIAN YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO OWN THESE. YES THE
FIRE ARMS YOU CAN GO IN GET
THEM IN OTHER STATES. THIS IS
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT OUR STATE
IS LESS SAFE EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE REALLY EXCELLENT GUN
VIOLENCE- PREVENTION OR
LIMITATIONS LAWS WE BECOME LESS
STAY SAFE BECAUSE OF PRACTICES
OF OTHER STATES WHERE IS IN
THIS CASE WE COULD BECOME MORE
SAFE BECAUSE OF THE PRACTICE OF
OTHER STATES. AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT IS A GOOD MEASURE AND
I APPRECIATE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL BROUGHT IT
FORWARD AND THANK YOU SENATOR
WINNER FOR PRESENTING IT. IN
WITHOUT SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR JACKSON FOR THIS BILL
AND IT IS TO PASS TO. BUT SEE
IS THIS ONE TO. YES DO PASSED
APPROACH. SO DO A ROW CALL I'M
SORRY SENATOR WIENER YOU WANNA
RENEW HELLO I CAN'T REMEMBER
THANK YOU MADAM DO I A FIVE
STRESS THINK THE ARE YOU TO
ADDRESS SOME RAISED BY. FIVE
ZERO CJ- AND SOME XIN ADVICE IS
A TO. LAW IT'S NOT THE SORT
BROWN BUT IN THE HANDS WE KNOW.
THAT UNTIL CONGRESS ACTS AND
DOES SOMETHING ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE WHICH IT'S NOT
REFUSING TO DO THE STATE'S SEEM
TO HANDLE IT ON THE STATE'S
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER AND
HONORING. EACH OTHER'S GOT
VIOLENCE OR ORDERS IS A CREDIT
PIECE OF ASK FOR I'M A. ALL
RIGHT THE DURRELL CALL IN THE
BILL IS SYNERGY MY DEEP TO UP.
AB TWO SIX SEVENTY DEEP TO
APPROPRIATE SKINNER BY DINNER
HI MORE LOCKED. MORE LACK AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D
JACKSON'S. JACKSON AYE.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE IN ORDER
MORRELL AYE MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE BILLS OUT. SEVEN
ZERO. THE BILL GOT OUT SEVEN
ZERO WILL NOW GO TO BELIEVE IT
OR NOT I CAN HARDLY BELIEVE IT
OUR FINAL BILLS- FIVE FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN. AND YEAH SENATOR
WIENER AVOID GETTING EXERCISE
SENATOR WIENER WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I'M
PRESENTING THIS BILL TODAY. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO.
AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN WILL
ASSIST LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
SOLVING GUN RELATED CRIMES. AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF ACCIDENTAL
GUN DEATHS AND INJURIES. IN
CALIFORNIA MANY GOT GUN CRIMES
GONE SOLVE BECAUSE MATCHES
MAYES. BETWEEN EVIDENCE OF THE
CITY IN A SUSPECT IN FACT NO
ARRESTS ARE MADE IN HALF OF ALL
HOMICIDES. MY CHRIS BEING IS A
CRIME SOLVING TO. PRINCE A
UNIQUE STAMP AUDIBLE CASING
WITH THE FIVE WITH THE FIVE TEN
ALLOWING LAUNCH TO THE FEDERAL
LINK THE BULLET. CASINGS TO
PARTICULAR GUN. THIRTEEN YEARS
AGO THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
LAW REQUIRING NEW FIREARMS TO
INCLUDE THIS FORENSIC
TECHNOLOGY- THIS LEGISLATION
TODAY EASES COMPLIANCE FOR
MANUFACTURERS. REQUIRING
FIREARMS MICRO STAMP ONLY ONE
PLACE ON THE INTERIOR OF A
FIREARM. AS OPPOSED TO WHAT'S
CURRENTLY REQUIRE NOW WHICH IS
TWO PLACES ADDITIONALLY AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
INSURANCE THAT ANY NEW FIREARMS
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA. WILL
FINALLY HAVE A CHAMBER LOW
INDICATOR TO SIGNIFY ONE OF
FIREARMS LOADED AND A MAGAZINE
DISCONNECT MECHANISM. TO
PREVENT FROM FIRING WHEN A
DETACHABLE MAGAZINE IS REMOVED
BOTH ARE CRITICAL CONSUMER
SAFETY PROTECTIONS FOR PUTTING
ACCIDENTAL. FREE TO COME AND
HANG ON MODEL THAT IS
INTRODUCED CAL. THIS BILL THE
ATTORNEY TO REMOVE THREE
PREVIOUSLY GRANDFATHER HANDGUN.
MODELS FROM THE ROSTER OF GUNS
ALLOWED TO BE SOLD IN OUR
STATE. I IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PANDEMIC GUN VIOLENCE PERSISTS
ON OUR STREETS FIVE CRIME IN
HOMES WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SUICIDE. AND ACCIDENTS FROM
IMPROPERLY STORED BRONZE. THIS
BILL WALKER QUICK LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH THE
TOOLS ARE REQUIRED TO QUICKLY
SOCK ON CRIMES. AS WELL AS
REDUCE ACCIDENTAL GUN DEATHS
AND INJURIES. AND WILL AND- THE
EXCUSES BE GONE IN
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY HAS
PROVIDED FOR WHITE. SUPPOSEDLY
COUNT MY FIRST STAMP- ODD TO
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN. OUR
BODIES START IN THE- PRESIDENT
OF. ALL FORTY. AND IT'S TURNING
OUT CML UP O'MALLEY FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK YOU. LET'S
HEAR FROM OF A- WE WITNESSES
AND SO. OF I BELIEVE MATHIS IS
GO FIRST GO AHEAD. I OPERATOR
MEDI SCOTT. OKAY JUST A MOMENT
LET ME CHECK. OKAY WE CHAU
MADDIE'S GUIDELINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY WANT TO JUST CHECK TO SEE
IF YOU HAVE SELF MUTED. I
UNDERSTAND FOR LINE MAY NOT BE-
HE- WHICH ARE SHE MAY HAVE A
BAD CONNECTION SHE HAD A
TRICKLE LET'S GO TO THE OTHER
LET'S GO TO NANCY O'MALLEY AND
THEN WE'LL SEE IF MADDIE SCOTT
CAN GET IN. SO IT'S GOOD IN.
YOUR MAYOR- MERRY SCOTT IS THAT
YOU. YEAH THIS MAY OCCUR AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVEN YES THREE
YES GO AHEAD AND THAT IS GOD.
MY NAME IS THAT IT CAN THE
PHONE FIVE POUNDS AND NATION.
AND ALSO THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE
YEAR NOT. AND ONE OF OUR THANK
YOU ON SOME FOR A LONG US TO DO
THIS AND ASSEMBLY. BIRTHDAY
CHIU AND- TO HELP US WITH THIS
BILL. WE HAVE SOME FRONT DOOR
EXACTLY. TWENTY FOUR AGO BY
DONE BY ONLY BUT IT'S AN
AUTOMATIC THE PERSON IS ON THE
LOOSE AND HAVE. THE BILL WHAT
ABOUT. ONLY OF THE FAMILY THE
BIT INTERACTIVE ART. THE
SOLUTION. DINING WOMEN OWNED
AND- BRING A LITTLE SUGGESTED-
FOR THE TRAINING AND TAKEN
LARGELY THAT MICHAEL STEPPING
BAIL- BELIEVE THIS BILL NOW
MORE THAN EVER WHAT THE PUBLIC
THINKS HE- I NUMBER. INCREASE
WITH THE METS BY. HE'S LACK OF
BROWN COMMUNITY SHIELD CASE
SHOT KILLED IN A DRIVE BY TWO
OTHER PEOPLE ARE GONE AND THE
PERPETRATORS REMAIN ON THE
LOOSE AND THIS BILL BEEN FINE
YEARS AGO WE WOULD. BUILD BACK
SO. YEAH OF BLACK LIVES. I AN
ACTOR AMERICAN PARENT STANDING
FOR THIS BILL TO BE WITHOUT OF
OTHER. THERE IS A COURSE THIS
STATE. BUT THEN I CASES REMAIN
OF WE THIS BILL. AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN FOR
MARK WITH. THANK YOU MISS SCOTT
LET'S GO TO NANCY O'MALLEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES AND THE UNFORTUNATELY ONLY
A MINUTE BUT GO AHEAD. TAKE AND
I'M ACTUALLY ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TREAT THE DRAG ON
BEHALF OF NANCY O'MALLEY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT ALAMEDA
COUNTY. IT GUN VIOLENCE
CONTINUES TO PLAGUE OUR STATE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE THOUSAND FIRE
ARMS FOR EACH LEGALLY PURCHASED
BUT THOSE REPRESENT JUST A
FRACTION OF THE GUNS THAT ARE.
BEING ILLEGALLY USE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SAMEER NEARLY
ELEVEN THOUSAND GUNS WERE
REPORTED STOLEN THIS BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN AND THAT THEY ARE.
THE CALIFORNIA AND SAFE CAN GET
ACT WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO PUBLIC SAFETY-
WITH THIS BILL FIRE ARMS WILL
MEET FURTHER BASIC RELIED. AND
SAFETY STANDARDS SEMI AUTOMATIC
FIRE WILL BE REQUIRED TO HAVE
MAKE RISK. WITH IN THEM IT'S
CRITICAL FOR FIRE-
IDENTIFICATION AND FIRE ARM
THINK AGES TO A CRIME TO HAVE
EDGED BY CHRIS IN CHARACTER.
I'M THE IT. AND AS SUCH THE
WHICH ARE LEFT AT THE SCENE BE
LAYING TO THE ARE THAT WAS YOU
IN THE CRIME THIS WILL HELP
IDENTIFY AND LINK FIRE ARMS TO
A CRIME AND TO THE PERPETRATOR.
IT WILL ALSO HELP TO LINK GUNS
THAT WERE USED IN MULTIPLE
SHOOTINGS THIS WILL PROVE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE.
APPREHEND AND STOP CRIME AS
WELL ENOUGH DOT FIRE ARMS
TRAFFICKERS. THE DA'S OFFICE
POLITICAL STUNT WORK AND HAS A
KNOWING ONGOING RESEARCH
REGARDING GUNS AND GUN
VIOLENCE. AND WE REGULARLY
WORKING TO WRAP UP SALINAS
ISLAND YOUR TIME YOU NEED TO
WRAP UP YOUR TIME IS UP. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALAMEDA
COUNTY D. IS A CATERED TO
INCREASING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PREVENTING FURTHER GUN VIOLENCE
YEARLY URGENT AYE VOTE. ON THIS
BILL THANK. LET'S SEE THE- NO
NEW WITNESSES IN THE ROOM BUT
JUST IN CASE ANYONE HERE FOR AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO TO THE OTHER
ROOM. NOPE SO LET'S GET THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN. YOUR IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD WE GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM LIMBURG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION. OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TEN LINE
AT ONE ONE ZERO. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MOTHER PRESENTING
THE GIVERS CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE ALSO IN. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR LINE OF
FIVE FOUR. THIS IS ACTUALLY A
CALIFORNIA THE DEATH OF. THEIR
OWN IMPORTANCE. IF MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED IN EACH LINE ONE
ZERO EIGHT. DONNA THANKS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. IF THERE IS ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT AS A REMINDER
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MORE MOMENT.
HAVE SOMEONE IN Q. IT'LL BE
JUST ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET
GIVE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
CERTAINLY. I NUMBER NINETY TWO
LINE NINE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
LINE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY PROCEED. I'M SORRY
I MADE A MISTAKE OF I WAS GOING
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK
YOU. IF ANYONE ELSE IS IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD
ONE THEN ZERO. I DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALRIGHT WE'LL GO NOW
TO OUR LEAD OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE DâN READ FROM NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION. AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD THE AND READ WITH
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND
THERE'S ALSO A SECOND WIND.
GENERATING YOU GO HEAD. WITH
THAT. I SAID THERE'S A SECOND
WE READY FOR ME I'M JUST
ALERTING YOU TO THE FACT OUGHT.
YEAH THE TOTAL IS THREE MINUTES
FOR THE TWO WITNESSES GO AHEAD.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
INDIAN RIVER NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION
ALSO YOU'RE GOING UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION- THEY'RE GONNA
ROSTER IN CALIFORNIA HAS
EVOLVED OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AS INDICATED BY THE
PROPONENT INCLUDING LOADED
CHAMBER INDICATORS MAGAZINE
THAT CONNECTS CULMINATING WITH
MY GREAT STAMPING- INITIALLY
MICROSCOPIC WASN'T IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE IT WAS ENCUMBERED BY A
PACKAGE. AND WASN'T CERTIFIED
FOR PRODUCTION TELL TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWELVE ACTUALLY
NO NEW MODEL OF SEMI AUTOMATIC
AND HAVE BEEN ADDED TO THE
ROSTER ESPECIALLY THIS LAW HAS.
HINDERED ANEWSPAPER LIABLE
HANDGUNS AND GUNS NOT ON THIS
ROSTER ARE NOT. NECESSARILY
UNSAFE FOR UNRELIABLE AS
EVIDENCED BY THE EXEMPTIONS
ALONG PORTS AND IN FACT THE
BILL THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
HEARD TODAY. IN COMMITTEE THAT
WAS PASSED IN AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE EXEMPTS ADDITIONAL.
LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS- AT THIS
PART OF THE HORSE RACING BOARD
THE STATE LOTTERY CALPERS
ETCETERA. WHO ARE GETTING
ELECTIONS FROM THIS BILL SO
OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE NOT ON TAPE
AREN'T THAT ARE NOT MAKING THIS
ROSTER. AND THIS THIS ISSUE IS
STUDY BY UC DAVIS A POINTED OUT
SOME OF THE ISSUES IN THE ROYAL
LIABILITY AS WELL AS- THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE. EASILY
DEFEATED BY CRIMINALS- SIX
CETERA AND WITH THIS BILL IT
REQUIRED REMOVAL THREE FIREARMS
FOR EVERY NEW ONE ADDED TO THE
ROSTER WHICH COULD ALLOW A
MANUFACTURED INOCULUM
MONOPOLIZED. AND CONTINUE TO
SHRINK- THE ROSTER THIS LIMIT-
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY IS
SAFER LIABLE FARMS WE CONNECT
EITHER SECOND I'M RIGHTS
WITHOUT. OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOW A MISTER FINLEY.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHAEL FINLEY FOR THE
RECORD I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION WE
ARE THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
AMERICA'S FIREARMS AMMUNITION
HUNTING AND RECREATIONAL SPORTS
INDUSTRY. WE WERE AGAINST THE
BILL THIRTEEN YEARS AGO WE ARE
AGAINST THE BILL TODAY WHETHER
CABLE PLACEMENT MICHAEL
STAMPING OR DUAL PLACEMENT
MICRO STAMPING THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THIS TECHNOLOGY DOES
NOT WORK. BUT DON'T TAKE MY
WORD FOR IT WHEN THIS COMMITTEE
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
CONSIDERED THIS ISSUE THIRTEEN
YEARS AGO THERE WERE TWO MAJOR
STUDIES THAT WERE COMMISSIONED
ONE WITH THE NATIONAL ACADEMY
OF SCIENCES AND ONE WITH THE
UNIVERSE. ORNETTE DAVIS EACH
STUDY CONCLUDED AND I QUOTE AT
THE TIME IT IS NOT RECOMMENDED
THAT A MANDATE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY ALSO MY ADAM
AUTOMATIC HANDGUNS THE. STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BE MADE. FURTHER
TESTING ANALYSIS IN VALUE. IS
RE. THE TECHNO IS QUALITY. I
WOULD POINT IT NINETY SECONDS
IS NOT ENOUGH TO GO INTO THIS
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE THAT HAS
OVER DECADES WORTH OF
LITIGATION. AND ON A DEBATE ON
IT I WOULD. ASK YOU TO LOOK AT
OUR TESTIMONY WHICH GOES INTO
GREAT DEPTHS OUT THIS. ONCE YOU
COUNTER WHAT- ON SOME OF THE
PROPONENTS OF SAID ABOUT THIS
BILL THIS WOULD NOT BE A QUIET
SOLVING TOOL UNFORTUNATELY NEED
TECHNOLOGY EASILY DISPUTABLE
YOU CAN FILE OFF THE- YOU CAN
BY LAW THE FIRING PIN IT HAS
LIMITED MARKINGS WHICH MEANS
THAT THERE IS A GREAT QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER IT WOULD BE
COMPLIANT WITH THE EIGHT DIGIT
ALPHA NUMERICAL CODE THAT IS
REQUIRED BY CALIFORNIA
ADDITIONALLY IT'S VERY COST
PROHIBITIVE WHEN YOU SEE THE
DAY MISTER THEIR STUDY. IT WAS
QUOTED TO YOU TWENTY DOLLARS A
FIRING PAN IT TURNED OUT TO BE
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
FOR FILING AND IN ADDITION AS
DâN REDUCTION THE TECHNOLOGY
IS STILL AND COVERED BY A
PATENT MEANING THAT IT ADDS A
SEE EVERY SINGLE TIME THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS USED-
ADDITIONALLY THEY HAD CAN MEAN-
SCIENCES REVIEW FOUND THAT IT
WAS UNRELIABLE MEANING THAT
POLICE OFFICERS AND DETECTIVES
COULD NOT USE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
MATCH A IN THE NATION WITH THE
PARTICULAR- HISTORY. ON THE OR
YOU NEED TO WRAP UP. WITH ALL
WRAPPED UP RAY NOW THANK YOU
CHAIR WITH THAT I WOULD HAVE I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU CAN OPPOSE
THIS BILL. BECAUSE THE
TECHNOLOGY SIMPLY NOT WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S A- THERE'S NO
WITNESS IN THE ROOM BECAUSE NO
DO PEOPLE WALKED IN THE ROOM
BUT I GET THIS SOON THAT SO IF
ANYONE HERE WANTS TO SPEAK
AGAINST THIS BILL YOU CAN COME
TO THE MIKE ABOUT IN THE OTHER
ROOM. NO ALRIGHT SO OPERATOR
PHONE LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO-
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO GET INTO
THIS PHONE QUEUE AGAIN THAT HE
IS ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO NINE.
NINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS WHALEN CHANG BUT
DISAGREE WITH LEGISLATIVE
FINDING IT STATED ON THE TECH
THE BILL I BELIEVE THAT THE
COST OF MAX ON FIVE DOLLARS FOR
GUN. HAS ALREADY BEEN STATED.
THAT THERE WAS ONLY FIVE
DOLLARS I THINK HANDGUN
MANUFACTURERS WOULD HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THAT RATHER THAN
CHOOSE NOT TO SO ANY NEW
HANDGUNS AT ALL. IN CALIFORNIA
AS ALREADY MENTIONED BOB BY THE
BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE THE
DIFFICULTY OF GAIN NEW HANDGUNS
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO MAKE
EXCEPTIONS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE SPLIT. SECOND
TECHNOLOGIES OF REASONABLE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN LINE ONE ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR OWN JUST
CONCERNS THAT IT'S A LOAN
CALLING IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WE HAVE. LINE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
LINE THREE ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THIRTY ONE WE DO HAVE THE
LINE OPEN. FIND THIRTY ONE IF
YOU WANT TO CHECKYOUR MUTE
FUNCTION WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. THERE'S NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE.
LINE ONE ONE TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CATHY LUNCH
REPRESENTING OUTDOOR SPORTSMAN
COALITION A CALIFORNIA GREAT
CLUB INTERNATIONAL CALIFORNIA'S
SPORTSMAN BLOBBY ALL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN IT IS ZERO.
ON THE PHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT
IS ONE TEN ZERO. IF NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU LET'S SEE-
PARDON ME I DO HAVE- LINE
THIRTY ONE THAT IS BACK FOR IN
THE COMMITTEE I CAN OPEN THEIR
LINE BACK UP THANK YOU. I WILL
TRY AGAIN FOR LINE THIRTY ONE
WE DO HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU. OKAY I DO APOLOGIZE NO
RESPONSE ONLINE THIRTY ONE.
THIRTY ONE HELLO. HI ELAINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU I'VE NEVER TOLD I WAS
THIRTY ONE THIS IS ROY MEMBERS
BEGAN ON THE APPLICATION WHEN
YOUR RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FOR ALL
THE REASONS STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. AND IF
ANYONE ELSE IS IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE PHONE KEYPAD. ONE TEN ZERO.
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS. MOVE THE BILL. ARI I
SENATOR MORLOCK JUST. A LITTLE
CLARIFICATION- ANYTIME A NEW
HANDGUN IS ADDED TO THE ROSTER.
THREE MUST BE REMOVED AND I
JUST AND UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT.
WITH THAT MAN IS AS- IF YOU
WOULD THINK IN A FREE MARKET
SYSTEM. I AM JUST TRYING TO.
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT EXACTLY
THAT MEANS AND FORGIVE ME FOR
NOT KNOWING OKAY- SENATOR
WIENER YOU WANT TO ADDRESS THAT.
I WOULD- ACTUALLY ACOSTA ME ONE
OR WITNESSES- ACOSTA MAYBE FROM
THE- ALAMEDA COUNTY DA'S OFFICE.
GOD OPERATOR COULD YOU ALLOW
FOR THE- BUT. THREE SEVEN.
HELLO I'M HERE NOW SORRY OKAY
GOOD. YOU WANT TO HEAR THE
QUESTION AGAIN DID YOU HEAR THE
QUESTION YESTERDAY CAN YOU
PLEASE REPEAT THE QUESTION I'M
SORRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU I I'M JUST WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW BURKE HAVE SOME EXPLAIN
WHEN IT MIGHT MY COMMENTARY
SAYS FOR EVERY NEW HANDGUN
ADDED TO THE ROSTER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
REQUIRED TO REMOVE THREE
EXISTING AND FUNDS IN. OUR
ARMED JUST CURIOUS WHAT THAT
MEANS YES SO CURRENTLY. IT WILL
IT WILL REMOVE THE THREE FROM
THE LAST WHEN THE NEW IS ADDED
ON. IN IN IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE. BUT THEN THE NEW
GUY AND THAT IS BEING ADDED TO
THE LIST THAT CREATES AN
EQUILIBRIUM SO TO SPEAK WELL
ACTUALLY MINIMIZES THE LIST SO
I'M ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT
WAS MADE WAS THAT IF YOU KEEP
ADDING GUNS TO THE ROSTER
YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING QUITE A
FEW MORE OFTEN YOU COULD
ACTUALLY ELIMINATE COMPETITION.
IN SO THAT'S WHY DINNERS AND IS
IT IS ARE THESE IS A LIST OF
GUNS HAND GUNS THAT ARE.
BLOCKING A CATALOGS. OR. HOW
FAR AWAY MAN I HOW DO I GET THE
IT'S A LIST MAINTAINED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOW LONG IS
THE LIST I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
GUNS ARE ON ON THE LIST ONE
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND I DON'T
KNOW CENTER OKAY. THANK YOU
VENTURE. CERTAINLY I'M ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE DíAS. MOVE THE BILL RATE
CENTER JACK. MOVED THE BILL.
CENTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THE FIRST RUN I WILL.
RIGHT AND. WE'VE GOT A MOTION
IS DO PASSED TO APPROACH
SENATOR JACKSON MADE THE MOTION.
AND WE WILL DO A ROLL ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN TWO
THE PASTOR PREPARATION SKINNER
HI IN OUR AYE MORE LOCKED. NO
KNOWN IN MORE LIKE CANNELLA
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON ONLINE MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MORALE. AROUND EL
SENATOR MARRANO WIENER. WHEN
OUR ONLINE. FIVE TO TWO THIRTY
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN IS
ABOUT FIVE TO WAS THE VOTE WE
STILL HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUSINESS WE NEED TO. THEY ADD
ON TO CONSENT. SO LET'S HAVE
THE RULE CALLED FOR THOSE
MEMBERS WHO WERE NOT ABLE YET
TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MITCHELL HI RICH ALIVE CONFINED
CALENDARS OUT ALL RIGHT AND
THEN WE HAVE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
ON CALL LET'S. FULL OF THOSE
BILLS IN AD THOSE AUTHORS WHO
WANT TO BE ADDED ON TO THE
BILL'S ON CALL. AB ELEVEN THREE
FORTY FIVE CRISTINA GARCIA
MITCHELL. MITCHELL ONLINE THE
BILL IS OUT RIGHT THE EIGHT
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE IS NOW OUT
FIVE. ZERO FIVE ONE NINE FIVE
ONE THREE FIVE ONE. YES GO
AHEAD AND THEN THE LAST FOR
LONG CALL AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX REYES WIENER. WIENER ON.
ALRIGHT SO AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX IS NOW OUT WITH IN
THAT VOTE IS REMINDS ME. FIVE
ONE FIVE ONE. ALRIGHT WITH THAT
THE WE'VE INCLUDED OUR BUSINESS
FOR TO DAY- WE HAVE MANY BILLS
FOR NEXT WEEK'S HEARING- BY A
WILL NOT MAKE ANY PREDICTION AS
TO WHETHER IT IS AS- EFFICIENT
AS TODAY'S OR NOT- BUT- I
REALLY APPRECIATE. ON MEMBERS
THE JUST THE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND ALSO THE WITNESSES WHO
CALLED IN AND THEY AUTHORS WHO
PRESENTED BUT THESE ARE NOT OUR
USUAL HEARINGS BUT I THINK WE
ARE ABLE AT LEAST TO HEAR THE
WHAT ARE THE CRITICAL CONCERNS
EITHER PRO OR CON FROM THE
FOLKS OF TESTIFIED CANNOT
AFFORD TO NEXT WEEK I THINK IT
WILL BE LONGER BUT YOU NEVER
KNOW IN. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE BUSINESS AND- WITH
THAT THE- THE BUSINESS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY CENTER PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR TODAY'S
HEARING IS CONCLUDED AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED.